welcome ladies and gentlemen to the
junior speed chess championship brought
to you by chess kid
i'm gm daniel naredinsky and it is my
pleasure
to be commentating an amazing match
today between grandmasters arjun
and omaraji bhukesh uh and an honor to
be commentating today with grand master
vidiq rafi
uh one of uh top players in india
how are you doing are you as excited for
this match as i am
i'm looking forward to it and more than
that i'm impressed with your
pronunciation of the names
good job well i was practicing all
morning
i don't want to disappoint you know i
try to do my part but i appreciate it
uh well before we delve into uh the
games in just a couple of minutes
uh we wanted to remind you of a couple
of things first let's take a quick look
at
the bracket as it currently stands
yesterday of course we saw
nihal seren delivering a scintillating
performance against
andrew tang and advancing to the next
stage
do any names sort of catch your eye do
you predict
any sort of early favorites as you look
at the bracket
yeah i think few names uh stand out to
me
uh i think uh sarana is a good player
and i see asi pinko he
it will be a very tough match i think
they both play against each other
i see uh perham who plays quite a lot
online
i think he'll be one of the favorites i
also see martirosian there
jeffrey chong so i think these players
really catch my attention i think
those are the players to look forward to
i would say agree completely
and um we do have a sort of statistical
forecast
a prediction that should be taken with a
grain of salt that prediction
says that nihal sarin will indeed be the
winner and
he will defeat san sebian another blitz
and bullet juggernaut in the finals but
once again that is to be taken very much
of the grain of salt so many of these
players
uh can't think in this prediction you
know uh
alexis sarana is maybe the favorite
against sam savion
just saying you know no i agree it's
definitely a lot of x factors here but
speaking of predictions we have our
smarter chess match prediction for
this match today um and vidit it is
giving an
overwhelming percentage uh probability
percentage to arjun
eridaisu what do you have to say to that
yeah i'm surprised but not so surprised
because
as you said you know earlier when we are
speaking that arjuna is really good in
blitz and he's always there on chess.com
playing blitz and you have played a
couple of games with him
i know gukesh better than arjun so i
know gokey she's a very creative player
and a fighter but i don't think his
skill set like his best skill set is
blitz
or the faster time format so i think
this prediction is correct
i don't agree with the percentage but uh
still arjun is like the big favorite i
would say
well we will certainly be delving into
that uh further as we
take a quick look at the format and the
time control
uh just to remind you we of course have
16 players
um and the time control is 90 minutes of
five plus one
then a break followed by an hour of
three plus one another small break
followed by 30 minutes of bullet one
plus one so one second increment
in all of the segments uh and we will
have that of course for the match
today as we gear up we will have liftoff
very very shortly um and uh as you
mentioned
definitely i've seen arjun around
playing so much blitz i've played
hundreds of games with him
he's definitely more experienced and the
ball
is definitely in groucases court
i think should have better chances in
the five-minute portion
compared to the other uh time control i
think he has to really set the pace
there
um otherwise if he gets down on uh the
scorecard
i think it would be tough for him to
come back
yeah we saw that yesterday with uh mihal
sort of
setting the tone i mean it was even for
most of the five minute board and then
at some point the halls just took off so
i
agree i think when you're the less
experienced player you know with the
five minute portion
it's a little bit closer to classical
chess uh so you have
you know sort of a little bit more
leeway and you mentioned vidit that
you said is a very creative player so
maybe that extra time in the five minute
portion will be to his benefit
and here we have liftoff you can expect
some kings indian from ghoukish
well we have right now uh arjun playing
white in the first game we have
queens gambits we had a lot of those
yesterday actually
and um a catalan okay
interesting dc a6 very trendy line
mm-hmm yeah completely not up to date
with
uh a lot of the theory but looks like
black is trying to keep the pawn
and yeah that's become sort of
fashionable hasn't it
is not supposed to be the main move like
knight fd2 is supposed to be the main
move
i played quinine to myself uh but if
black plays accurately he's
more or less okay here well here's up
the point
he's kept upon for sure where is white's
compensation coming from
does he go for knight c3 and uh not
really i think
the idea is to uh play bishop b2 maybe
sometimes and bishop d695
those kind of ideas uh then you exchange
off you know the bishop
and you get some play or you can play
like bishop d2 rook c1 and knight e1
so the idea of bishop d2 is that you
don't allow knight to b4
and then it's kind of awkward there aha
so there's that tension and you go for
the c5 square that's a really
interesting
so it seems like you can play this more
tactically you can play it more
positionally
um but arjun taking his time here
exactly he seems a bit uh surprised
wrong moment to think
if you're entering this line uh but i
expect bishop b2 seems much more natural
than bishop d2
i agree it seems a little bit less
awkward um
and uh
putting the pressure immediately it
seems exactly
these lines where you i don't know
giving up a pawn for positional
compensation and blitz it can be
difficult to prove stuff
when you have such limited time on your
clock but here we have 95 immediately
i really don't like this move so if you
take
bishop b7 i think is the point rook b7
d e now knight where should it go
uh well it's actually not so simple
because knight d5 there's
maybe 95 with the idea of putting it on
b4 but then
um yeah night before you have rook d1 is
what you
[Music]
are oh well first of all after knight g5
i can ah
rook takes a6194 here yeah but then
rugby one right
rover d1 yeah exactly black is nice
it's gonna be dangerous it doesn't feel
like the most uh
appropriate way to play i agree can you
play knight before but then it's a
concession yeah knight if i played okay
bishop b7 so i guess we'll see
maybe knight d7 but that felt a little
bit awkward to me knight b7
you could consider going rook t1 you
could consider taking on a6
and 965.
you know if the pawn is lost so white
needs to be very careful but maybe rook
takes c6 is more prudent let's see what
so he's thinking arjun is thinking after
knight d7 this seems to be a critical
moment
here in the early going to the first
game what do you think what do you
expect rook d1 or rook a6
i think rook a6 because if knight takes
e5 you can attack that knight let's say
this would be too that seems to be a
little bit less of a risky continuation
yeah what do you think yeah rook a6
seems good
then maybe 95 bishop b2 uh
bishop d6 that is f4 always right oh
yeah and then g7 potentially falls
now queen d3 i thought but that leaves
the eighth rank exposed
that's actually really the yeah okay it
looked nasty there
i mean maybe but king e7 is there's no
way this can
possibly survive i mean even an end game
doesn't seem particularly appetizing
so yeah so rook takes a6 to me at least
looks
risk-free it looks natural um but
there's definitely
something to be said for trying to keep
the c5 on
very interesting like very exciting game
right away not like a boring opening
they're going for the board exactly both
of them
um and i i i agree with you i like this
approach for boucase to try to
put the pressure early in the five
minute portion um
but obviously the question of will it
backfire we saw this yesterday you know
they're not afraid to spend a lot of
time
in the first you know 50 moves trusting
especially the more experienced players
like argent
trusting their abilities with seconds on
the clock
i missed the match yesterday okay how
dare you leave the comments
that's it completely unacceptable
completely unacceptable well it's a bit
late in india so that's why
i don't want to hear about it you've
said all all i needed to hear so rookie
one in fact played
now queen a8 is that what we were
thinking uh lucas might choose
yeah right
yeah and let's say black just develops
with maybe bishop
yeah yeah knight c3 i want to play
knight b5
for example yeah so knight b5 is a bran
maybe knight c5
oh knight b5 knight p3 there's like rook
takes a six ideas
i would never take knight b3 yeah like
castle in the first
yeah yeah the first second you have yeah
exactly so bishop b7 that's what he's
trying to do
but that creates its own problems with
the knight on d7
um so rook takes a six here is he
intending to castle
and does white have any way to
potentially exploit this knight maybe
queen f3
aiming but then there's like knight
takes e5 ooh yeah
95 is a nice tactic by the way and the
rook on d1 hangs just
for the crowd here if queen takes b7 so
a lot of really sharp tactics here
and not a lot of time anymore to
consider it before
but rook a6 castle i will not be like
upset now with white like at least i got
my pawn back i'll play bishop b2 and i
think
it's better for sure a little bit yes uh
and then maybe rook and swing over to c6
yeah maybe he's like displayed somewhere
in my opinion black misplayed
i don't know where but it definitely but
why is urgent so slow
on the flip side i was going to say two
minutes to the good here for
and there we go rook takes but that
seems such a natural move
and yeah definitely it seems like
bouquet has to castle here otherwise
there will be hell to pay after queen
frequent c6
uh yeah yeah yeah he has to castle maybe
queen c8 is an option
i don't know uh but yeah i'm not so
happy with black's position to be honest
right once i dislike a position it's
very hard for me to
like it back no i i completely agree the
pawn has been
recovered and a lot of positional
pressure so bishop b2 is the simple
movement he's done and
now has to unpin it himself it would
seem to me maybe queen to c8
at least try to liberate the knight get
some sort of
leverage there and rook c6 maybe rook b6
giving up another pawn on b5
yeah but then it's like slightly tragic
like you're just pointing around
yeah yeah you thought you would at least
be upon up and suffering now you're on
down and suffering
oh my god rook c6 there we go but this
rook is like a splinter a knight v8 just
doesn't seem very appetizing even if
you've got c5
in that weakens d6 yeah
also knight c5 sometimes you have to be
careful about some bishop a3
stunts but right now it's not working
because of b4 yeah
maybe just queen c2 for example right
and you're threatening to take the
knight
so what's the current position okay this
is the life yeah this is the position
and this is a good move i like it good
movie great yeah
just laying down the wood here and these
positions like if you
solve one problem you know it's like you
open the door to four other problems
um and that goes for like if you play c5
you weaken this d6 square and then
white's nike head there
or knight f6 i mean there's a million
things awaiting black i have no idea
what to do here
just develop jesus i think he'll play
with him
uh he's still thinking he'll blow up
trust me on it
i'm trusting a hundred percent rook d8
no but that's a mistake i think quincy
too you're absolutely right
and the knight has to go right yeah yeah
because it threatens with 65
yep yep knights mistake i think he can
he felt the pressure
usually in five minutes if you think for
one minute on a move
that means that something is wrong at
least on the board or in your mind
something is
like just not right there because you
are like okay hesitating
and you don't really want to think for a
minute right and
usually the pressure on the position
makes you do that
yeah that's a terrible sign you're not
satisfied with anything and here i think
has to accept the inevitable keep that
time advantage
now after 97 it's definitely not losing
yet white has to prove
exactly how he's going to make progress
he can triple on the c
file and i know i hate to say this but
bishop d8 keeps things together fitted
for the time being
but now maybe then i can just head to
like four or something like that
is this the light position the light
position is rook d
bishop d4 okay so he's gone with d8 he
had some ideas of uh
infiltrating to d1 but now he has to go
back to d7
now this one right yeah
is this like just lost i think it is
because now to see seven point falls and
yeah but i think you're the expert of
surviving such positions
i'm the expert at dirty tricks lagging
and
the one second increment it really as
we've seen in the early going of these
matches
it really changes the dynamic a little
bit
um but not a ton you know time scrambles
are still time scrambles
so i see that uh aran
hawaii was in the chat and he said a
while vidit has appeared i guess he's
referring to my hairstyle
which is again not out of choice but you
know due to the pandemic
everything is closed oh yeah i know i
can completely
concur upkeep is not
easy uh but i think it looks good
now bishop before might be playing nah
94 yeah yeah the knight oh but then
we'll see seven i in the rook indeed
yeah i think we should not be good
good move bishop if it is good 94 anyway
is possible he decides to release the
tension now go knight e4
now the knight potentially gets to be
six seven seconds four
windy five good move yeah i love this
time pressure part
oh it's great buckle buckle your seat
belts guys don't forget we need four
going for the queen trade very practical
decision it seems to be by argent
oh nice i think black played the last
couple of moves better than white
i agree yeah popping the queen back
maybe
what would you do two seconds left yeah
yeah yeah
h4 improving the position slowly queen
bacteria preparing knight c6
stopping it look at the prophylaxis by
um
every thread seems to be by origin yeah
and he loses
yeah that's the worst you should never
lose on time yeah that's like
yeah that's the worst now the position
was of course
incredibly difficult but yeah i hate to
be the backseat driver but sometimes
video you just have to make a move
you just have to make a move yeah a
big time score uh here by um
by origin good game by the way the
victory
very good good game very controlled nice
effort yeah
gurkish played well in the opening part
like opening face put some pressure but
somehow uh he couldn't sustain it and
once the pawn was gone i already felt a
bit
uh you know i lost a bit of hope there
for black
yeah it's just psychologically very
difficult to play those positions
where you've lost that one thing you've
suffered for
and yeah we have a king's indian attack
here um now as this game
is is still in its early stages i think
we can take this opportunity with it i
noticed that um recently you've been
participating in a really interesting
project
that involves master classes by a lot of
top players
and i thought that was really cool could
you perhaps tell us a little bit about
what you've been working on and what
that project involves as
this game proceeds from the opening to
the middle game
i mean uh right now you must have seen
that even during olympiad
there was like so much of interest and
at the finals
in one of the streams there like 68 000
people watching so there is like a
certain chess boom in india
and many people are interested in the
game
so which is very cool um and there's one
company called
an academy which is like one of the
biggest education giants in india and
now they are like moving into chess
which is like
really awesome because it could really
lead to a lot of new people
playing chess which is of course very
nice and what they've done is they have
decided to make a platform it's an
education platform so
all the top grand masters of india are
teaching there including me like there's
anand
there's me and uh there might be even
kramnik joining in soon you know fingers
crossed
so big players are there any actual
strong players in it like
qualified instructors
that's awesome yeah they contacted
robert hess but he was too busy
[Laughter]
yeah so it's very nice so every other
day i'm giving a master class
and like basically taking through my
journey
so anybody if uh is there from india and
they want to join
it would be great uh it's an academy and
it's a discount for they have an early
discount right now so they can just
use uh with it 94 there's a code and
uh join in yeah it would be great to get
master classes from
how do you spell the academy is it a uh
you said uh sorry sorry sorry
i'm speaking too fast an academy u n
and i'm going to type it into the chat
you and
then academy yeah yeah yeah i like that
absolutely of course i mean that sounds
like an amazing project i'll check it
out myself
and awesome to hear that you're
participating in that video it's
it's so hardening to see chess boom all
across the world
particularly in india i've noticed a lot
of
gm's are doing some incredible streams
um instructional
and playing blitz and it's great to see
so much engagement um just
very very heartwarming uh what else is
heartwarming
i think is white's position here now i
never really know how to evaluate these
positions
it looks really good for white but if
black just closes things up with f5
how extensive do you think white's
advantage is here
did it um
i wouldn't say it's like a big advantage
it's just a game right
uh i would my first idea is to play like
rook d1
and i want to play knight e2 and c4 like
break through
there um otherwise go g4
but yeah these two ideas come to my mind
it's too soon to say though
yeah g4 i was thinking maybe black can
try something like take stakes and h5
undermining g5 square i'm not really
worried
yeah then you have this and then this uh
yeah i really like this
i think to some people it might seem
like the weakness of f5 is significant
but really
white uses it almost to his advantage um
so i think that's a great point he does
play knight e2
you really do know wow that's pretty and
e3 so
implying that maybe he wants to play b4
and that is immediately stopped by
argent
so again the question now for lucas
which side of the board does he want to
try to make progress and centralizing
his knight for now
definitely unpleasant did it here do you
like white do you like white positions i
love white well i have a particular
fondness for these kings indian
structures
yeah the idea of g4 the more i look at
it black could meet it with g6 now i
don't think black's position is
you know in danger of imminent collapse
but your idea of c4 i think is actually
really really good
what's this also then there's like a
very cool idea bishop f2 bishop h4
going for those dark squares yeah at
six you so is he is he trying to play g5
does blackjack
work his straights and counter play
i guess so i mean otherwise what's the
point but g4
g4 i would go for it right now right
this is a great opportunity because
yeah i guess black can go g6 now your
idea bishop f2 bishop h4 hunting down
those dark squares in the king side
that looks very very nasty i mean maybe
now black takes me goes h5 but really
nothing has changed and then you know as
nimsovich told us one of the sort of
founders of positional chess
you know you play on one side of the
board and then at the right moment
you switch to the other and that can
have a devastating effect for the player
that's kind of cramped
um not that i've really ever read my
system from cover to cover that's
um i think nobody really read it it's
like peer pressure you know everybody
says it's a great book
and then you just join in and say yeah
yeah it's great but nobody has really
that exactly i was gonna
talk to you about that and get the
perspective of someone who's
actually really really uh good at chess
and you know there is see there seems to
be this uh these set of books right
then game manual that all of the gm's
like it's unacceptable to be a gm and
say that you haven't read it except
nobody really read more than a full
couple of patients yeah yeah yeah i
agreed 100
it's really important it's just like one
player sees it and
you're too afraid to contradict and you
say yeah
it's a good book and we really don't
want i mean i'm not saying it's a bad
book but
the point is uh nobody has read it page
to page
um right i believe that nowadays it's
better to like just uh
learn from your games and uh there are
very few books which really interest me
anymore i think this positional decision
making by girlfriend is like really cool
i liked it
but most of the books are theoretical
which you can't really like you know go
through it's like a
task i don't like that when you have to
read a book as if it's a task
right it has to be for enjoyment and
nowadays reading competes with so many
other
stimulating activities it's just hard in
general like you know i like reading in
general but it's been hard but
yeah this whole you know pressure of of
reading reminds me of my school days
when i would
you know i'd get assigned a huge portion
of reading and i would only read the
first page but i would read it very
carefully
so when the teacher would test the
students to see whether they had
done the assigned reading i would raise
my hand and deliver this elaborate
analysis of the first couple of
sentences of course i did not read cast
though in any case now we have some
developments in the game that
if arjun has castled long i kind of like
what he's doing here
yeah yeah very practical very practical
he wants to go g5
so i was thinking maybe queen g3 g5
f5 but there is bishop f6 is there i
mean
it's a bit messy what was that avoiding
the undefended queen
you love such stuff i mean you i i do
tactics exactly
i do now take stakes i do like really
like this idea for black
because even if white secures the pawn
with d4 and we have some developments
here
without further ado we have b4 and
totally understandable the case trying
to rip open that queen side
but arjun has time white does have the
eventual idea of breaking through but he
has a couple of tempi to whip things up
maybe g5 in this position has to be
considered
but i'm going to let him do the
calculation as i sit back and sip my
matcha green tea i love to watch other
people calculate
that's the commentator's job so how do
you comment it when robert is there he
never calculates anything
but his intuition is legendary um
you had to join me you have to join me
in the roast of robert
let me down there oh no i i trust me
and i'm just warming up i'll roast them
like you've never seen
i'll roast them like you've never seen
um
yeah g5 played wow
so obviously i like i want to play a 595
bishop b6
like go white wow but there's knight f3
there's knight f3 attack counter
attacking the queen bishop c7 91 bishop
dude what the hell is going on
totally okay let's see what happened d4
has been played he's
who's the pawn on e5 i don't like boring
h5 now looks pretty interesting
knight g5 hg just set things ablaze
and then take on g5 go bishop g6 but
that's but okay
this is a little bit not very good maybe
yeah
this doesn't look like black really has
anything maybe he does more harm than
good
but is it like a generic russian accent
or it's like someone specific
generic but okay i can try to do
them no but i try this way it's more
like alexander grisham but
okay oh wow no but i appreciate it very
much
try to do it as best i can but but i
mean more that's like vegan gaming this
is more like rambunctious
but i mean okay i think you know this
way that way okay
no but conceptually i think bites would
be weak but
is white winning here this is actually
very messy and we're entering the time
pressure stage no no
the fight is not at all winning i think
it's but okay
but what is transition i would take
black i mean any day
go h5 next move
and white hasn't made anything happen on
the queen side
yeah yeah maybe three so like h5 you
meet with g5 but still bishop b4
yeah it looks it looks bad and now he's
trying to
get the oh look at bishop f5
nice and time pressure nine seconds to
say this is so much harder to play for
white
looks like the wheels the roof has come
out here for cash bishop takes g4
uh oh this is about to get very ugly h5
here is possible
at the very least and he does it b5 okay
he's trying the best he can but
black sub just comes first bishop g5
with a four
[Music]
he doesn't even care about he doesn't
care
[Music]
arjun is playing more consistent not
necessarily like the best moose
but more consistent throughout and in
the last minutes gurkish is losing
control like
d4 was a bit like too timid now
no i agree with zero man 2-0
rough rough start um and you kind of
called it
uh it just you have the sense of of a
very experienced blitz player very
practical
um and okay struggling in these critical
moments um
as you said maybe playing a little bit
too conservatively yeah
how do you do you make these adjustments
during the match is that
a thing you can do sorry not not to
interrupt you
yeah no this line is very interesting
because i've played like five games with
this knight d2 knight c4
very hard practically for black if he
doesn't know because just for a pawn you
get like
huge initiative uh even in the end game
of course yeah such positional control
and knight d4 is already a mistake after
b5 is supposed to be the main move this
is like you know bit ugly mm-hmm
this looks really nasty yeah yeah yeah
and people need to understand that even
with the trade of queens
that doesn't mean black is doing okay
he's not
yeah because this catalan bishop yeah
that's that's a monster it's just
dominating it's paralyzing the bishop on
c8 and
i think bishop c5 maybe i have a feeling
because he's thinking so much what else
can you do he took on
and f3 okay that does seem pretty
reasonable i think but
queen beat three and rook d1 or wait
wait how would you go about this
that does look pretty good actually um
what else can well bishop g5 maybe also
um not such a big fan of bishop g5
because i don't know what's the thread
there
i was thinking bishop takes up six also
with it you're not supposed to criticize
i
only 2700 plus players can criticize my
moves oh wait a minute
um so yeah but i agree bishop takes f6
and 1966. and you know he might just do
as uh you suggested because you both are
like really good in this online blitz
and maybe the thoughts match
no but the more i look at it i i i
decided yeah
um and i think we b3 is the is the sort
of classroom though maybe there is a
reason that you're 2700 and i'm not
you're being modest since when what
happened to you
well maybe one day so he's thinking so
he's definitely
you know weighing the options here a lot
of candidate moves he can also
oh whoa queen a4 wow
i didn't see that so b5 what exactly is
his idea does he want to take
bishop yeah queenifer might not be the
move no
knight d6 cd and you just held black
what if we go
here and then try to go after that d6
yeah but like you're suspicious
maybe even knight d5 and you might be
out of the trouble i don't know
yeah ugly queen not to mention that
bishop d7 is also possible
did you even consider it queen
check no i didn't see it at all honestly
very interesting this junior players
they surprised
me with their moves many times uh they
play some moves which i don't ever
consider yeah
yeah it's you know you it doesn't even
enter your field of canada moves i agree
that always it unsettles me because i
think
wow were our thinking patterns really
that different but apparently so
with with young players as you say
huh and bhutish taking his time here
definitely deciding between b5 and
bishop d7
what to do
he'll play queen b3 bishop b5 what do
you think it's fun to predict moose
should be five i agree because bishop
takes b7 rook ba
white runs into some trouble although
you're not really not sure
yeah just just with that bishop back
much like the first game just recovering
the pawn saying i'm better
and that's what he does yeah what about
okay b5 may be too crazy or maybe just
castle yeah
just castle yeah i agree i think that's
the most practical and then maybe white
goes rook d1 and keeps the tension
queen doesn't cash in quite yet yeah
ah and you have to be a little bit
careful of queen trap ideas
yeah yeah but i think maybe if you take
and then take
white has multiple ways of definitely
getting an advantage
a minute and a half on the clock almost
like you know i really like to see
matches which are like extremely close
so i'm hoping like you know at least it
gets a bit more
uh closer and you know down to the last
last
section you know that would be much more
fun than
it being one-sided nothing any of the
players though
no you're absolutely right and i think
we yeah i mentioned this yesterday it's
not like we're rooting against the
player who has the lead but
as with everybody we want excitement and
action and actually it does play v5
i thought it was over the top but i
suppose now the
idea is of course to get this bishop i
would take it i would take it yeah
i have a reputation of being called
greedy vd so i would definitely take it
like
any i agree completely no because i just
don't see the play in return for that
also that pawn on d6 is very weak you
could follow up with queen before
and if okay rook the one kind of same
concept if black goes d5 then you could
put the queen on your board
and stop like
queen v4 looks nasty yeah
queen before and it's a dream dream
position maybe a5 like black can
do just enough to dislodge maybe queen
a3
with that in mind is a little bit more i
wanted to play queen before
and b3 bishop a3 but maybe it's too much
yeah
yeah sizzling down that diagonal now
between a3 it stops black from chasing
the queen away
i think he's deciding between those two
moves watch him play something
completely different like
f4 i think this is going to be one zero
i can yeah we can easily count it like
very hard for white to go wrong i think
after queen a3 there's
black is no moves and then you just sort
of develop bishop before c1 and then you
could put the bishop on d6
yeah should extra reinforcement be
necessary yeah
i think in blitz do you think like uh
the defensive
um what to say uh the skills of defense
are really important like what are the
most important skills for blitz play
according to
you're one of the experts here well i
appreciate it i mean
i think this sort of tenacity in
defending
that's got to be the single most
important um
just given my entire experience at least
in my sort of view this ability to
not only create just cheap traps but
actually defend objectively which is
underestimated i think people think when
you're defending in blitz
it's all about dirty traps it really
isn't i think a lot of it is actually
about finding objectively good
defensive uh options with it um and
trying to defend objectively find the
best chance
but i also think you know things like
improvising and unfamiliar openings and
posing practical problems
forcing your opponent to make a lot of
decisions is another
underestimated skill because that sucks
at a lot of time who would you consider
like the world's
best players in blitz maybe online we
don't even consider over the board
right now right online in three plus
zero with no increment i would say it's
very close between
carlson and nakamura i would
i would if it's increment i would side
with carlson
and within bullet like one minute test
i would go again i would go ali reza
hicaro and magnus as sort of top three
very very close even ali
yeah you would put him in one oh
absolutely if he's
on his game and he is a little bit more
prone to tilt i think
than the others in that category but he
can
i mean his 30-second chest is is the
stuff of lesbian
or you folks can trust me it's like he
literally has the power of telepathy
he's like i mean it's crazy
the way that he predicts moves the way
that he can convert a position
with one second left a slightly better
end game
it's it's unbelievable honestly it's
just the sight to me
i should check that out someday because
i think nowadays most of the chess is
going to be online
and i think this online skills are going
to matter a lot
in my opinion well you ain't too shabby
yourself with it
i'm there but like i'm like 3 000
30 50 like you know that's my peak uh
but not not more than that i want to you
know
uh it would be nice to reach like 3100
yeah i mean a lot of it really is sort
of having a good mouse and
and mastering the mechanics of time
scrambles which
a lot of to a lot of players is of
course very distasteful and they think
that's not real chess but
you know the question is do you want to
i felt that in our match
yeah it's but at the end of the day i
mean you just
need that kind of stuff if you want to
achieve the specific rating gains
so you never feel guilty about flagging
anyone oh i think that you're past that
stage yeah
i actually do because i used to not feel
guilty i used to also do it more
obnoxiously
i've introduced a couple of rules for
myself when i would say okay
you know these types of positions i'm
i'm not going to
go after my opponent i don't feel great
about it but
at the end of the day you know you it's
online chess
you have to do what what you have to do
you got to do yeah yeah
and stay i think fighting back castle oh
yeah
yeah i mean like i didn't think he would
ever castle i didn't think white needed
to allow that
um i know i think white is still winning
for sure whoa whoa
this does no rook f7 what what was rook
f7
so close you know my instinct here is to
just exchange queens
yeah that does not seem like a bad idea
and pinned along black is completely
lost
he's gone from the frying pan into the
fire now
yeah big difference in strength um we
have to be objective
and say what it is so far the story
arjun playing much much
better gokesh giving it too easy at some
point like this b5 move
it's like after that you can't really
fight back you know that was a big big
mistake
do you think he has to modify radically
his opening with black maybe go for a
king's indian or something to that
effect
um he can but i feel like there's a
big difference in strength right there i
don't think opening is the
biggest issue it's just pure practical
strength and arjun is much more
conscious i haven't seen like a big
mistake from arjun so far i can't recall
one where he has like
uh you know played a move which is like
not even like top five or something
and we have a rouser uh here
so and uh yeah
i love this opening by the way i used to
i've played like 300
uh games in this line it's my one of my
favorite openings from black
yeah and it's it's become more and more
popular it's so rich um incredibly rich
with so many different
uh options yeah now
we have a couple of treats uh for the
viewers as we uh
as we observe this opening go into
the uh middle game we have first and
foremost
live odds and vidit it was very
overwhelming the prediction
it's gotten even more lopsided 93
to 7 the current live odds
uh according to the statistical
prediction for uh
what's the best of this odds is if you
can prove it wrong
that satisfaction would be amazing but i
don't see it happening today
well if it does he's gonna have to start
winning very quickly but definitely very
lopsided and uh
this is going to be interesting but the
second thing that we have
uh for you are actually a couple of
photographs
and they're not just any photographs
they are photographs of the players
as their younger selves now they're not
old but
even younger selves and we want you
ladies and gentlemen to guess the age of
arjun and bhukesh in these photos that
you see
before you i'm curious
whether anyone could predict the
neighborhood
i mean i would get this wrong what do
you guys think
you have seven oh someone wrote six and
three i mean
definitely not three yeah
okay we have some close let's see eight
and six
eight and six tenants ten and eights
then i actually don't see anyone getting
both exactly right but
you guys are very close wait do you know
do you know the answers
i think i've well i've i have the uh
cheat sheet
so to speak but i i can i guess as well
or
yeah please do i actually want to hear
you guys um
okay so gucci is i think
six or seven i think i would call six or
seven
one of these and arjun is uh
nine or ten i think ten yeah i would go
with ten
you got one of them right and i think
arjun is indeed ten
uh and drum roll please
and i don't know if i'm supposed to
reveal this yet uh but yeah uh
uh is actually believe it or not nine
in that photo nine he's under nine
tournaments was uh
but okay it might be an under nine
tournament but he could just be like
seven as well
right under nine doesn't mean nine but
apparently he was in fact nine years old
i can't believe that i can't either so
you're saying in these
in this photo there's only a difference
of one year or less
yeah crazy anyways ten and nine
is the word that we perceived as we
transition back to the game
and here i actually think uh
has a pretty promising opening now
you're sort of the rouser expert i
i find it very difficult to evaluate
these positions i wouldn't let you
approach this i would never ever put my
king on b7
never ever always on dark square i never
put it on light square
interesting um now g3 i suppose will be
played
uh i think one of the ideas is like to
play knight e2 knight f4
and uh maybe some queen h3 if
you can get it usually the bishop goes
to h3
but even queen might work or there is an
idea of knight
to knight f4 knight h5 i don't know
whereas black actually puts the king on
b c7 or something and plays b4 a5 e4
so he's attacks on that flank so i love
this opening for black i have a preacher
dice
towards it so maybe you can take white
and pose me problems
yeah i definitely if you like an opening
for black i'm definitely taking
i would never even think of it now one
thing that i
i've i've sort of seen is the idea of
going b4 and then e5
is there anything to be said but now we
have bishop c4 because the knight
can't really get to d5 this looks nasty
e5 was ugly
oh wait it happened or not oh 95
happened yeah i was supposed to
game but what i'm really worried about
is an e5 breakthrough for white even
sacrificing stuff
oh nice yeah ready has to be considered
in some positions
don't want to calculate anything
specific what is knight f5 what is
knight a5
bit weird i love this e5 idea of yours
though
pretty cool yeah i mean even here it
should be considered although d65 was
thinking of like a check
but who knows oh rook d7 here
oh let's see very cool very good
we have 92 he's taking sort of the more
measured approach
actually and i have uh news for you
is actually six so i was right
six or seven i was right
we were misled uh slightly but you were
absolutely right yeah there was just no
way i mean there's a limit to what's
possible how can you deny that i mean he
looks so tiny
yeah exactly in any case now you're
right he moves the king away to a7
uh he says let's get it out of the
danger zone in the window of opportunity
but
for playing e5 and following up with the
check has passed i'm not sure about 92
well he follows up with knight f4 as you
mentioned knight comes around to see
five
nice
[Music]
queen at six yeah yeah i was wondering
knight h5 is it an option
that's actually one queen d that forces
me yeah and then
the other knight can come to d4 if
required oh queen e3 by the queen e3
also interesting yeah not sure what to
make of
well then queen be said
get on the screen yeah exactly just get
on the board yeah but i'm sure he i mean
this game i i think you can send it i
think he should play for it like play
for them maybe go to catch e1
just and go bishop f1 bishop h3 i mean
you have complete control
even if you play like something solid it
shouldn't be that bad
because black is stuck how do you even
play with black now
yeah no no attacking chances going
nothing going really so
virtually anything is good in blitz do
you think it's sometimes
uh better to play like
fast and like uh what to say
swapping no fast and like uh the normal
moves whereas not trying to find the
best moves but just
play a decent move i would say 100
better
than you know trying to find the best
moves absolutely and i also think
that that there's like a middle ground
where i sometimes tell myself
okay i'm going to give myself until two
minutes and then i'm gonna make a move
regardless of whether i
i'm satisfied with my search um
and that way you can compromise a little
bit you know you can search
uh but you you know
you don't just whoa who what
i would never ever that is crazy now
he's limiting the night
uh but what cost what what cost
i mean it's i can't refute it
immediately but i don't like it
e5 now yeah it just seems so drastic now
maybe
no i think he'll play c3 with the idea
bishop c2 but c3 d5
maybe and give that pawn put knight and
the knight on d6 this starts to unwind a
little bit
yeah i think yeah
it's such a high maintenance move yep
yep yep
you know it's like before you
it's one of those things you just
intuitively don't don't yeah it doesn't
look good
yeah yeah and i think if you even put
engine i think it must say that b4 is
not the move
definitely e2 okay so now bishop c6
i guess does not threaten bishop b4
because there's queen e3 with the four
he does it anyway you see such tactics
so quickly
one more tactic that's that's basically
all i see that's what i have to make a
living off
but i don't think that helps white
because it's not like why you can use
this tempo
to do anything what does white even do
um yeah good question maybe it'll catch
you one and play bishop
back to d back to d3 and this is a huge
sign that things are going
very very wrong this is the game would
you play a5
yeah i would i would introduce this
tension
but on the other hand white goes a3 now
i would try to get d5 in at some point
the problem is this bishop on c6 is
counterproductive he goes i like this
new king b8 yeah
he's drawing the king out of the danger
zone rookie one may be white white
should be considered
oh look at you one idea d5 95 maybe you
know
oh the bishop is undefended i'm learning
from you man
learning from here no that was that was
nice now
it's not easy for black either h3 now by
location sort of preparing expansion
with g4
knight f6 queen f6 or knight f6 yeah
queen f16 is more proactive he does go
knight f6
without a doubt and then take queen e6
also
he does
what to do for black now yeah queen a5
takes yeah he just says i'm not taking
any chances but
wait what happened so he gave an
intermediate check
okay and this is i love what he's doing
though knight f cities
now ruki's g3 yeah queen c7 oh 997 nice
just goes out between d4 forces the
creature and wins the bishop
and now you won or you take the bishop
he's making sure the straight queens
look at that he's saying i'm not going
to take that
i'm training questions yeah
and trap the rook actually yeah he'll
resign good good game for kukesh
finally makes a comeback b4 for the win
wow so it it paid off i suppose although
man man did he go through a lot there
oh charlotte chess center in the chat
shout out that's
my good friend videomaster peter
gionatus is
welcome welcome um got the whole
contingent here
um yeah so another catalan
and the fact that that bouquet is
thinking tells me he is probably
rambling to find a different line
maybe we should be seven i don't know
yeah just do something peaceful you know
at least
get out of the opening be careful here
good that it's at least 3-1
indeed indeed it goes for dc
okay oh it's persistent now before this
gets interesting
uh the producers are telling me we do
have a photo of lucas when he was nine
um which we are just going to show
because we have to save face
and there we go that is the photo of
vacation now everybody needs to be
impressed and look at this photo for a
couple of minutes here yeah and gurkish
is clearly visible there
yeah very amazing i think this was like
ansel adams actually took this photo or
some famous
photographer
it's so much fun to troll though but
we're i'm being asked a question by um
the production team
about how you sit at the chessboard i
mean is you know
everybody has their posts right some
people grab their
their head with their hands some people
cross-legged some one thing
i myself do sometimes is sort of i don't
know how to describe it but you like bob
your leg up and down and then you make
the table shake a little bit
yeah wait a minute now breaking news
alert what if c3 c3 knight b1
that's the three and b4
yeah this is completely out of my aha
wow
that's really cool but he's not taking
time he doesn't know about it
the point just to show the the people
the audience is just after 86 before
this rook hangs so you cannot retain
that wedge that you've built in
now is there a particular seating
position that you usually take or do you
kind of change multiple times for the
game
i i think i've i think b4 a3
rook b8 like to remove the from the
bin is the theory aha so and and try to
retain this one and there's a very nice
move like
a b now you have to take it bishop b4
queen d3 at trying to take the pawn on
c3 you can go e5
and stuff you know e4 is an important
move though
and what's the nfd trade queensland yeah
yeah wow
but the fact that he's got less than
three minutes tells me that he's out of
theory
definitely yeah yeah without a doubt
yeah that's that's problematic i think a
b there's like an option of going c2
queen c2 knight d4 knight d4
bishop g2 and then knight d6 in terms of
intermezzo and then take bishop
okay so we'll see he's got knight e5
now what about c2 here
oh and the queen takes into that mighty
force significantly
no longer did this happen probably let's
see
it did that might have been an oversight
by origin
with no bishop c6 okay
and then i got my c6 but what if
this should be oh bishop e7
and 25 yeah without this bishop the
catalan is just not the same animal
okay nice nice stuff okay
so fun game decision game this is big
for goquest but
if you want this one i mean it's a
one-point game so
yeah no big damage has been done and
this is a big moment
when this match happened do you feel any
pressure when you play them
uh what do you mean you mean when i what
do you mean by that
let's say if you are in that position
would you feel any pressure of playing
or you take on lunches like little bit
more casual
definitely and it's really it's about
the people it's not really about the
prize one for me
it's about the number of people watching
they know that a lot of people are
watching
sort of it's an official event um and i
personally know when i played the sort
of katara
uh tournaments i i just my hands were
literally shaking
whereas i can play a match against you
know i don't know some
carlson or something casually and i
won't be nervous at all so it really is
it isn't about who i'm playing against
for me personally it's about the sort of
the stakes of the event
but that's just my own experience i'm
sure they have their own
things that make them nervous or less
nervous
interesting so you're not worried about
karl schulzen if you're listening
uh this was an open challenge by danya
i'm always honored and it's
you heard it oh it doesn't matter it's a
good move by the way
i like it yeah exchange of the bishop so
we do have a situation where white has
given up that light square bishop out of
necessity but
queen d5 can be met with f3 it's not
like this is mate
yeah yeah i like what white did now good
stuff
maybe you should not have allowed this
bishop a3
um right now what if we well
a5 isn't impressive really i mean maybe
you should play it just to try to limit
the knight on b1 but again i mean little
k8
yeah yeah bishop a8 and yeah
pretend that you're better yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah but if it's a good move
though
good movie a5 maybe knight is like the
best way
after that and here we go if i play
would you play knight c3 i would i
probably would
nice just get it out while you can
so so far like in these games what have
you noticed about gokesh
and arjun if you had to like draw some
conclusions from their games
i just think the word that comes to mind
to describe arjun is extremely practical
i mean i'm not getting the sense that
he's necessarily better at calculation
per se
but he's putting himself in positions
and he's putting vocation positions
where
it's difficult to make the right
decision and as you pointed out uh
lucas just doesn't seem to be making
good decisions
in critical moments i think it's all
about the critical moments
there's two or three points in the game
that just seemed to go arjun's way
now some connection problems it seems
here for vacation but he's back online
really
quindy6 i think maybe should be
considered
queen d6 because there's ideas of of
forking
the knight on deep line which of course
is going to happen because
yeah it's not but yeah i like white's
position i would pick white
what about you i actually kind of like
windy sex
i don't know yeah queen d6 takes takes
through kate rogan
94 and you know
yeah i don't know
yeah so 95 i'm actually not sure who i
would choose
i suppose the time situation is also a
big factor here two minutes
extra for um
yeah for argentina yeah yeah
goku is a bit slow i would say
comparatively and it's one of those
positions like in all you can have
there's so many options here like when
do you play queen d5 do you play f6 yeah
like i said before it's like gucci has
to make all the decisions
and arjun is kind of simply reacting and
that actually can be a very good thing
blitz
but i agree white's now better the
knight comes to c5
okay now knight c4 yeah right i don't
want to play e4
no definitely that seems too committal
yeah yeah queen d8 and some f5 stuff oh
he just done it
definitely queen e8 only seems to be
playing into black sands
five queen b5 he played okay knight
queen six queen c4
he does he played he played queen eight
winning five seconds
g4 seconds only
that was a big mistake oh wow queen c7
now no
no or queen c3 we should be queen c3
queen c7 would have been
but he's got to become three seconds
here but he's got a good position he's
played
what is his idea you want no no no he's
losing control he's completely losing
control here
he's giving white
cannot leave yourself with two seconds
in such a middle game quite simply
yeah it was like golden chance like you
got this queen eight you had to go f5
it was a big chance
i mean one to four back to a three-point
game and we have another rouser and we
have 34 minutes left in the five-minute
portion and it seems to me
um well first of all it seems to me that
lucas is having
some connection problems because we see
a red bar
i don't see red bar where is the red
on his oh yeah yeah oh yeah yeah oh yeah
yeah i was just looking at black yeah
yeah internet issues
i can write a thesis on it
they are the worst there that is one of
the most tilting things
just possible so
yeah e6 yeah yeah i mean it seemed that
white had a
fantastic position um and
there's just so many options in the
rouser uh
for black i mean so many setups it's
hard to keep track
of with white yeah the only line i
praised
and their arjun lost right
yeah commentators first oh i think
has some big internet issues he wouldn't
think for so long yeah he's taking a
minute already and we can see that he's
not in a position where
he he wants to do that yeah i this is
bad news bad news
because they are like arjun is a good
player you have to have time and
yeah that's not looking good at all so
if you were sort of his like boxing
coach after the five minute portion
is that what you kind of tell him um try
to
play pastor follow your intuition yeah
but you know
um i i'm like
objectively i feel that there's a clear
uh difference in strengths
arjun is playing much better than kokesh
without a doubt
um that's the so that's an issue so for
me as a coach if i was a coach i would
be very hard to lie to him and say like
okay you can do it and you know this
or i would just like tell him um play a
bit faster
um trust your instincts like don't
hesitate i see many times he's
hesitating
um keep in like a buffer of 30 seconds
and just go for it like you know results
don't matter you're like
uh he's just like what 13 14 whatever
like very young
and just take it as an experiment and
just play freely because i feel he's a
bit
like constricted he's not playing freely
he's like little bit tensed
i don't know that's the feeling i get
i'm gonna make a bit of a
controversial statement and i and i
don't know if there's any sense in this
it seems to me that there has been this
shift among young players
where earlier when i was growing up it
was all about being impulsive the
players
everybody was all into blitz and really
fast
and now it seems that actually young
players have gotten so deep
in their positional understanding at
least some of them that some of them
blitz is just not a natural thing for
for quite a few
young talents nowadays is that the
styles have diversified from what they
used to be among young players
i don't know i just got distracted
because even though
arjuna was thinking so i got a bit
distracted there when you're asking that
question
maybe you wanted to make it fair uh i
know i
know what you're saying do you think it
could be the reason because he just
thought for a minute to make the times
level
some fair play thing going on there nice
maybe
that would be very gracious indeed and
yeah well i was just saying that you
know
it seems to me that when i was growing
up the young players
were all very tactical very impulsive
everybody was into blitz and now
we've gotten to a point where some young
players are so deep and actually so
positional
that blitz is not natural to a lot of
them which i think didn't used to be the
case but i don't know if there's any
sense in that
no i don't think you don't think so like
nihal he just like
lives on chess.com but not not all i'm
saying
some are as they used to be but i feel
like at least
they play even more now because due to
online it's much easier to play blitz
so i feel they play even more uh of
blitz
but just the thing is like the strength
in overall has increased because many
people are doing it
so that bridge is not there like you
cannot stand out just by
uh playing couple of hours of blitz you
have to really invest time now because
there's a difference between like an
expert and just being good at blitz
because i think is good at blitz but
he's not three thousand
right yeah you just sense the strength
of the experience in every single game
every decisions that he's making
exactly yeah so
and yeah so they're both taking their
time we have another sort of
maybe they're talking to each other
right yeah just discussing the position
nikom's step for pressuring e6 but yeah
is there any
pressure here um
knight c5 he seems to be a fan of yeah
he does love this maneuver
now the knight on c5 lens support of
course to the e61 how exactly does white
continue the pressure does he go knight
h5 and queen h6
c3 i was thinking about this i didn't
ship c2 and put knight on d4
although right yeah
i mean that's just like two moves i see
i don't see the rest of it
one thing to point out just uh is that
this does not succumb to a flop because
knight t5 comes with tempo exactly
you can't you can't resist when this
when there is a tactic right oh no i
have to show it yeah
i just have to i have to show how proud
i am of myself finding a one move tactic
bishop c2 played and for
margin there was a chat which said can
we have a match between vidiq and daniel
i can tell they want to play
i do want to play whenever i commentate
i feel like oh man i also want to play
oh when i play i feel like sometimes i
want to comment it as well
100 um you just get into the sort of
zone um
and you feel the juices the competitive
juices fly how about before again
oh my god i can't
believe it i was joking but no but
there's some sense to it because the
bishop comes to b3 and you pressure e6
how about fe first and then bishop b3
because bishop b3 immediately maybe
there's
although even but still yeah yeah yeah
yeah but knight c7 oh
he loves these knight maneuvers bishop
b3
uh knight c7 i would even play ba maybe
ba queen a5
fe fe and i got excited for no reason
yeah i wanted some knight c6 ideas but
they don't really work
pretty so he's got a3
and now bishop d3 and it seems still
knight c7
how about def d is a classy move classy
movie a3
nice right i like that you can go bishop
a2 sometimes queen a2 if required
nice stuff he's he's playing these
positions very well sort of making a
measured move
when he needs to and then acting when he
needs to he's at a great position here
when he gets before he feels he feels
the position well
yeah it's like it's his move now what to
do now for
arjun is there even a does he kind of
sit and wait maybe lend some support to
the e6 pawn with the rookie eight
um not an easy position to play for sure
white's portion is like you can even
play king of one and just like wait and
you're still
doing good um yeah this seems like a
very important game
uh h5 so he but that settles him with
another weakness
you know why did he even consider oh it
takes knight g6 maybe
oh nice and then taking this take 56.
you're so good at this quick quick well
i sort of asked myself what the drawback
is
right when you move upon like this it
sounds primitive but you have to check
the squares
i appreciate it i didn't see 926 at all
i was only thinking
yeah i mean once you take the pawn right
it's pretty bad for black yeah yeah
it's a very good tactic i think i don't
think he has seen it
he can do it still here even maybe even
stronger
yeah but it's a very good tactic thanks
i mean
what a bishop b6 though and then you're
like no
you can actually take twice
oh no but then some queen six queen c3 i
would just play like knight d4
yeah definitely enjoyed that he's done
it but he's he hasn't got like g6
oh he lovely knight d5 no knight f5
but it's still okay but
yeah this is this gets a little bit
messy but the point is now after ef
the bishop is hanging so you cannot well
you can take the knight
but that's the idea look at the light
square control now instituted by
cache
what is going on here now white is
definitely dominating beta i think
yeah yeah yeah for sure without a doubt
but still like you give a lifeline
oh seriously i would never see because
now it gives black this pawn majority
even though you have light square
control if you ever lose it black will
have d5
yeah oh it's strange maybe rook c1 now
i don't love what he's done though yeah
rook c1 i really like he's done it
and then maybe knight d5 and take queen
d5 and penetrate with the queen
oh yeah so somewhere like there if you
trade the knight he's gone d5 there we
go
very practical decision again we see the
practicality by arjun
and i'm sure i think uh lucas is
regretting
you know in retrospect finding that blow
now knight 65 his idea is what just to
take and go king a75
yeah and then rook c8 rook c8 and okay
black is
worse but okay it's not like lost or
something yeah white's king is is
of course very weak as well and that's
where the time right
was up on time now now
does it look right to you does it now
bishop d5 though
but king a7 rook c6 rook c6 comes in
rooks is definitely gonna play gotta go
quickly here
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah i just gotta follow his intuition
bishop e6 instead
crazy complications here definitely
looks to be in white's favor
96 what about just rook g8 or something
okay bishop c7 no queen
he's going after the pawn he can go
queen eight or maybe we need to queen
into queen e2
maybe queen it too but then i'll take on
e6 and i'll go bishop b6
and i'll claim that i have some chances
look at the clock again this is very
concerning for a bouquet she's below 20
seconds he's got
a2 rook to you know seven e7 e7 he said
yeah
swing the knight around he's got
activated works he fights
okay bishop g6 play quick
good movie seven forcing the rook to tie
it
up
yeah 95 yeah oh or even queen c6
just yeah and resignation
much needed win oh he has one only in
the classical sicilian
so fun
now this is a huge win and
this game i think fitted he showed this
improved followed his intuition for the
most part although he did
you know there were some chances here
and therefore for arjun as well
and they're off for i guess this should
be the last match or no there's still
still 23 minutes left i think maybe
they're resolving some issues
and we have a karo khan so arjun's
switching it up
[Music]
in a very fashionable line it's been
played in blitz against me so many times
i've seen it everywhere
these days this line with knight f3 and
d3 would you change
from a winning line like i don't think
goku had found a solution for this no
i was about to to say he definitely did
not
so there's some deep psychology involved
here
knight f6 is a bit weird now you've got
d4 now this looks
very good is this a very bad french or
am i missing something
i mean he's considering e6 i'm sure but
is there a need to do that no no no no
no yeah just reasonable
just d4
knight f6 is definitely not not the way
maybe you go g6 you try to make a
gurganidzi out of this
h4 g6 is the move which robert has would
play
right exactly i would defeat him there
with h485
and then designation would ensue shortly
thereafter
yep and he's
thinking maybe like also knight v6 is
trying to get the bishop out i think
that actually might do
but then even like a4 you can meet that
with a5 so something like this try to
get the bishop out
not great but at least something he's
done
he played c5 c3 yeah normal
i mean again i can see the temptation of
going but there is just no need to
engage in this stuff when you're much
better
yep or c4 um this is one of the
dc i mean a lot of good moves for white
but c3 is simple and proven
yeah but they're thinking so much for
like the initial
moves which is a bit surprising for me i
always thought that
you have to play a bit faster um
earlier on right but they're taking time
i think the most fun part is when they
get down to seconds
that's the c4 wow so he's yeah i thought
about but i thought maybe e6
and no e6 then cd and then you have this
like
weak or the structure yeah
with knight c3 so this you're saying
knight c3 and you start pressuring the
pawn
yeah maybe dc and knight b6 so d5 is the
idea
oh d5 is the idea i thought it was
well i guess we'll cd on queen a5
wow nice nice
now getting back heading back they did i
think here
if i go knight d2 and bishop c4 there
this
black is not out of the woods yeah i
missed
this 92 move maybe that's what he's
thinking about
no but i think he still has to do it i
don't see an alternative maybe knight b6
here
also is to be considered but but then
even e6
i don't know it's easy to sacrifice
other people's pieces as they say
i see a comment which says be careful
hess is a legend on twitch
i think not just on twitch hess is a
legend in general
but that doesn't mean that we can't rule
him that's exactly
it's why we have to troll him and
robert is a good sport he'll he'll
understand he always does
yeah he always does this um
so big time decision here again as you
said move seven and he's gone for a
queen a5 track yeah 92 good move yeah
maybe 96 then but then e6
e6 i know this looks terrible
but can you play f6 and try to just take
both of these pawns
yeah i was thinking about it but i would
just like play bishop d3 and
give the pawns oh and just there
as well also there was knight d4 in show
of bishop d3 oh just here yeah yeah
definitely
stuff yeah yeah so he's got an ipd2 i
guess you have an ip6 it's happening
very interesting
uh starting position yeah some sort of
advanced fischer random here not that
there's anything going on
in that realm um
so e6 and knight takes d4 are possible
but yeah e6 teams fun game very yeah
i mean eight moves in we've got a very
unorthodox position
so e6 f6 knight d4
so queen takes d5 you could throw in a
check on b5
knight c6 yeah and i thought maybe
something to the effect of
wow sorry knight f3 maybe
uh push up e6
and maybe knight c6 oh what no castle
bishop d7
i mean
right no exactly exactly you just gift
me the pawn and he's got a four
that did it he's got an e4 and he's
preparing to should be five and queen
[Music]
well the thing is right black can
potentially establish this knight on d5
with e6 and then
he'll begin the process toward
development i think he can even play
castle now
we should be fine i'd be three maybe or
something i don't know wow
that's really cool idea two different
should pay four though
queen d4 i pretend that i'll have seen
it from
knights
[Laughter]
oh my goodness what madness oh but now
you can you can even move the queen away
yeah but then queen b5 and it's the
thing
yeah um
okay so knight takes d4
is also a move a lot of fans of your
impression in the chat by the way i
appreciate it yeah i see
what's your favorite i think your grisha
was the best grishok impression i've
seen
i mean i i have a lot that i you know i
sort of do on my own stream that i'm not
sure i'll do
during the commentary um but i i
do you know i've been working on
i've been working on youtube no i can't
really do an issue i mean i can try to
do a yander pony show which
sounds a little bit like a niche but
it's okay but i tried to join
but it sounds a little bit like an issue
anything maybe with a little bit more
accents yeah
it does sound like nepo though when
you'll speak uh
uh yeah but i i've you know i can try
vichy i've tried um i'll get modera
kasparov
kasparov is the one i've practiced the
most of course
okay can you do it or it's uh yeah
yeah you know i mean you know my first
game you know gets plugged here it's um
you know it's it's good to be resuming a
new chassis
you know even though it's a line you
know i managed you know to
create some changes after that you know
you know
in the time period you never it some
mistakes you know but overall you know i
think we're quite happy with
with the result of my games and you know
we'll see
what what happens in the day too
[Laughter]
i'm sending this clip to gary
yeah close by you'll just hop in a car
it's
like eight hours away
um but yeah there's a there's a couple
that i'll
reserve sort of for my stream but people
say your wesley impression is the best
impression that's what this is yeah
but can i do it in a commentary though
i yeah no it's very what i and i think a
lot of most people are understanding
that i
love these guys i respect the heck out
of them
and wesley is one of my heroes so when i
when i do these impressions it's not out
of some sort of disrespect
um or or mockery at all it's actually
the contrary and
everybody has been understanding but i
also try to be very careful about making
that very clear
yeah i understand because sometimes when
i'm like streaming myself
and i make like a roast of anish or
something there are few people who get
hurt and they think that
they take it too seriously right so i
know what you mean like people can take
it
uh with the wrong intention an intention
is just to have fun to make it
you know a little bit interesting and
then uh people take it in the wrong way
think that we are cooperating yeah
something no completely same with vishy
i i
[Laughter]
i'm working on that i mean i've got
moderate to i've been working on carlson
is the one that has eluded me
what was that i said sorry about that
what do you want from me what you want
me to do
[Music]
do you want me to let just straight out
the opening and take it all the way to
the end
is that's that's how you win smooth game
i mean i can't really it's it's in
pre-production here so in any case we're
entering
time scramble phase it seems like white
is actually
doing decently i don't know what's going
on here i would take white though
yeah clearly for one time bishop but
what is black coast bishop g7 and
castles one thing is that there is a
four gonna be seven yeah yeah
so you have that in your pocket you can
go queen before b3
yeah yeah that may be queen before
oh no where's the queen trade queen
before is so nasty i hate that move
that's my one role in life with it now
bishop d2 very measured
very practical arjun twelve seconds
though by the way only
right now he's gotta take this home this
is a big chance for me
face knight queen d7 this has to
stabilize
again
[Music]
yeah 27 castle i mean he's got the
central control here
yeah why is he thinking queen f6 doesn't
feel like queen b3
right the knight is unprotected attacks
b7 oh
yeah but still i would take the pawn
queen and start taking the point
two seconds
to stop night of four let's see six
seconds now 96 trading nights
we should ship c3 but he's training off
a lot of pieces
what's going on here day two quincy
three oh no no
iron
some work remains to be done here for
boucase rook c2
then you go around through the other
side but b5 is going to draw
yeah b5 before you're never sure but
yeah
yeah i see you've got to just run that
through and be three
no i was wondering even if you can go
king you want king d1 king c1 but that's
a bit too much
whatever the 11 minutes ago very
practical player that's what i noticed
how we handled the
position d3 he just went rookie four
like exchanged pieces
very practical player one thing which
i've noticed about him
i agree completely it's not that he
doesn't take any risks but he does
you know he just takes the air out of it
and he's up two points there's no need
to go crazy
now he's gonna place he gonna play this
for another 50 moves
now again you can lose this i think if
you if you're not careful
this is losable i've definitely lost you
know
these types of engines all of a sudden
it's like you're posed with problems
really yeah
i think the rule is like you keep
attacking the
f3 pawn and yeah rook k5 is also good
you just
like do like a fortress there right but
you start pushing the pawns and you know
with two seconds you can panic
h5 yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah i'm telling
you i think
oops i'm bad thank you yeah
i'm telling you a minute this is scary
oh time diamond f5
oh my goodness oh my lens oh
and it's still a drop probably yeah
there's no
i have no idea how to draw an f6 f6 when
both the pawns are there
it's just winning yeah oh it means what
but it was already lost i think no but
still rook jiwan king
i know yeah yeah is a heartbreaker
oh my goodness i i guess i i relaxed and
i thought it's a draw but you
your instincts you know your blitz
instincts knew well yeah i could be one
being these situations and it's amazing
how many chances can be generated if
you're just not
very precise uh you know increments and
that is a hard record that
that game will be a critical i feel like
yeah five
two and now it's uh probably the
deciding game of this um
yeah i think should be possibly i guess
this
is the last game i'm not maybe depending
on the length of it but the way that the
games have been going yeah probably so
we haven't went over with queen a5.84
um
i think dcbc c4 is one of the moves here
yeah i think negi um analyzed the
heck out of this position in his books
um this is i've tried to play this line
with a4 never had
any success with it played it against
fabi and
got it handed to me but um
yeah that was fun h5 now i think uh you
take on f1 and play f6
maybe because your knight on c6 is
better than knight on a6
yes but you don't want to allow h6 right
so yeah but i thought bishop f1 first
yeah rook h4 should be played good move
yeah and there we go
f1 now dc is potentially a threat
yeah maybe knight quincy what knight is
seven i don't like this move dc and c4
right dc when you try c4 takes yeah and
then rook be one bishop before something
you know
right this can spiral out of control
very very quickly
i didn't like this movie that's actually
how fab you beat me i allowed something
to this effect but king juwon is playing
it slowly
okay but now g4 like this is not scary
that's not enough kimchi one
king jung was a bit weird now
yeah but now dc is a big threat so do
you play c4
but then g c d maybe c d
c d g four you form still yeah knight
takes the knight
for queen f3 nice
castle though but g5 i mean again it's
not like this brings black any relief
yeah you know what i was just joined in
the score is like 5
2 in favor of arjun and this might be
the last game
of the five minutes section and yeah
things look good for arjuna big favorite
right now what if c4
here c4 here
dc d5 and just boom goes the dynamite
dania style it indeed and uh
well excuse me queen c4 takes takes
basically
before he did no he took first
and then c4
but i still like it right he's ripping
open the position
one has the feeling that things have
gone quite a bit wrong here for black
what would you play though like next few
moves are important
yeah it's like a critical moment right
if black castles goes knight c6
black might very well be better but yeah
yeah i don't think it's as bad as it
looks
no i agree i agree maybe queenie two
queen takes c4 just like practically but
it's just like life you know it's not as
bad it's not as bad as it seems yeah
very profound i like it we need to play
now these end games can be very
double-edged um
i would prefer black though much easier
to play sometimes
um with this knight so what do you do
here do you castle
yeah i would just cast and maybe okay
but that pawn on c5 concerns me a little
bit
um it doesn't to me like takes a knight
no but yeah i agree rook ca yeah i can
see what you're saying
although yeah bishop h69p6
just had to point that out i cannot
resist so knight d7 played okay
daniel is the chit great coach and
player to lots of fun
ah well thank you mark i appreciate it
it was a chat by the way which i read so
no i know i i'm saying yeah but you know
so um as we uh have a
lawyer as they're pondering these
critical moments we just wanted to very
quickly
update you on the odds um as they have
progressed we see the bobble heads
moving hither and better but we see of
course still
a huge um advantage in terms of the odds
that has remained uh i think that's like
a live graph of the percentage as the
games continue
but we see it basically started around
90 it moved a little bit up a little bit
down but it still remains there now
fancy fancy stuff indeed indeed
we have every kind of measurement and we
have 89 percent
in favor of margin i think it's shifted
from 87 and then it was at 91
but three point advantage i mean i can
understand
still i and again i want to make this
very clear
we're not rooting against the player in
the
lead but i love seeing close matches so
from that perspective
let's see what uh goucase can bring to
the table why do we look at how arjuna
how relaxed he is
look at him now he looks so chill oh
right when i said that he leans in but
he looks like almost sleepy and like you
know
like it's not even a match he's like
just there right assume casual games but
he's yeah like you said everything about
him very practical
but was it practical to give away the c5
pawn
yeah that was not the plan why would you
do that i guess rook c8 is what he wants
and goes or actually it's kind of
interesting when i look at it
why though but i mean you can just play
rook c8 and go knight b6 now
this is a bit fancy too fancy for my
liking
i like simple stuff i'm a simple man
right and i agree like bishop takes b6
even then rook takes you rugby one
i feel like white's out of the woods for
sure but case really has to try to win
this game three minutes 50 seconds left
my guess is that there might be one more
game after this one
but we'll see him yeah we have like four
minutes
or how much yeah three three three
thirty basically
um 3 30 basically
guys do you think in the chat there will
be one more game i doubt so
i think it might go down to the y well
it depends on on whether arjun is going
to take his time
looking how how relaxed he is i think
he'll take his time he wants to take his
time
okay people in the chat say no
no this is the last game perhaps perhaps
i have a feeling there's gonna be one
more game but what i've learned
from my match with you is that five
minutes is this neces not necessarily
the defining factor
so the game game still the match can
still turn around
oh we can turn around yeah but i mean
for goku i mean adjustments have to be
made on his end
uh without a doubt group b5 bit
ambitious
um i guess not a bad move though not a
bad move
yeah so rook takes c2 he i guess he
wants this right he just wants to take
maybe 95 will be played right now
it is
okay oh wait people in the chat say he
could reach 3400
what is bullet edition so they added 150
points to everybody's bullet rating
just.com did a couple days ago oh i
didn't know about this
yep i think to counteract uh some sort
of
uh deflation so i i logged in and i was
like wait wait a minute
i don't remember being 3200 yeah so it
was crazy i i didn't know about it until
it happened but icaru
was i think 33.80 and then he hit 3 400.
okay nice now i
actually what is going on here
who is better because these knights are
incredibly jumpy knight before 23
seconds for goku
i am most worried about the time
situation here burgo cash
yep yep he's a bit slow bit slow knight
f3 but he wants to win we can sense that
by this movie movement b5
bishop b4 will be played in my opinion
then
a6 and a5 a67
yeah a5 a5 yeah yeah then maybe rook
ace yeah but there might be food yeah
yeah looks like it's potentially
fizzling out into a drop maybe a6 or k5
right away go for it that was a good
move
right keeping that extra pawn yeah noun
a5 yes
bishop d6 rook c4 you know he might even
lose this because some knight f4
idea is knight h5 i don't know a bit
scary bit scary knight f4 93 knight f4
92 i don't know
a lot of threats with 16 seconds you
know you're absolutely right knight d3
93 though
g3 a good move i in my opinion just stop
the knight from coming
back great move i agree now he's going
to take and come back to f4 maybe
yeah all rook c4 first oh no then there
is uh
then there's a five yeah yeah yeah so it
looks like this will be the last game
oh my goodness oh rook c4 are very
dangerous but i like this for white this
is actually easy to play for white
because you wait for it to take in a go
c4 are you sure
is it like it's a extra pawn oh there is
an extra i didn't see i thought it was
ankle material but still i don't think
this is
this is wow why did i do that again
i'm pressing something on mouse now
let's see no
i think losing this would be terrible
for him he
uh i guess i would say five yeah yeah i
agree i agree
yeah yeah yeah but four seconds still
time is up so this is officially going
to be the last game shot was correct
yeah e5
f6 right allowing this knight to come to
b3
should that be necessary you know the
worst thing for me is when you lose
a winning position i hate that like i
can't stand it
because i feel it's unjust it's nothing
i don't think it's unjust but it's just
the worst yeah as you said
it's the it's the worst feeling you just
it's the most tilting i agree
i guess from experience whenever there's
a passport in blitz there's always the
possibility of a swindle but
again arjuni just doesn't allow swindles
he's so he's so practical he's so
careful
king fa very measured this is a disaster
very practical as
that's what i've noticed here when you
see these games live you
understand them players better now
mm-hmm no that's they
i agree completely that has been the
sort of deciding
factor even perhaps was the practicality
and the strength of course as you
pointed out yeah
still not over though let's see how who
cage handles this
he's actually doing quite well
his favorite moon i'd be seven yeah
now oh my god
d6 does not work rook c3 or maybe rook
d5 55
rupees oh rook c3
no and then f6 look at him this is
losing just f6 ties the pawn and
yeah it's that there's going to be five
yeah f6 king d3 king b4
is over and that is a blow
blow for vocation what a performance in
the five minute portion
four uh the predictions were not so far
off i think it was something like seven
two or something six and a half two and
a half
and it's yeah yeah it is 6-2
and that is definitely a blow forward
cage however
the silver lining for him is 60 minutes
of
3 plus 1 coming up
and so he's going to have to make a
serious statement here
as arjun arigaishi uh coming out to a
four point lead after the conclusion of
the five minute portion
well we have to let the players catch
their breasts
before the start of the next portion and
we have to catch our own and i'm sure
you do as well
when we come back one hour of three plus
one coming right up
[Music]
welcome back ladies and gentlemen to the
junior speed chess
championship brought to you by chess kid
we have
the three-minute portion of the match
between
two shining stars of indian chess
grandmasters domaraju lucas
and arjun igaisi coming right up
first let us update you very quickly on
our smarter chess match prediction which
indeed predicted a lopsided victory for
arjun
and well it really hasn't changed it
came very close to the truth um in terms
of
the five-minute section i believe it was
6-2 right at the conclusion of the
five-minute portion so
basically it's predicted the lead and in
order to beat the odds
lucas is going to have to make a very
very serious comeback he's going to have
a
have to make a statement early in this
three-minute portion
uh and we will have liftoff any second
here what are your thoughts on on how bk
should approach this
uh does he have serious chances of
overcoming the odds and overcoming the
leads
so i think in our match uh when we
played the score was like five
two or five three something like this
and um
and then you uh covered a little bit in
three minutes and then in one minute you
just took the lead right
so it's still possible to do that and i
guess in three minutes what he has to do
is like reduce the margin i don't think
he can
cover it up but even if he like closes
the gap to two
points that would be a great uh victory
for him i would say
so absolutely that's what he should aim
for like keep realistic games
i don't think it's possible to like
really uh kill it with like you know
cover four point margin
he goes
of course i'm very biased but i agree i
think that you should and you shouldn't
think of it as i have to come back to
make up every single point it's one game
at a time
and uh stay in the game as they say you
know coming back in any sport basketball
you hang around until the fourth quarter
and then
about that that run in the last seconds
yeah i like that he has already gone for
kings indian like you know i don't care
i'll play kings and i'm sick of your
catalan stuff
already a nice vibe there and he plays
this king's indian positions well i know
him
he likes this his coach also plays the
king's indian i know his
vishnu he plays king's indian himself so
he enjoys such stuff i don't know about
arjun
how will handle this it will be
interesting because it's very practical
but in king's indian
it can get out of hands so very clearly
and one thing in the king's indian is
you could be losing and
there's always this chance for counter
play no matter how lost you seem to be
so
exactly that's one of the practical
elements of why it's appealing
not only a classical chess but
especially in blitz do you think
yeah no but i there is this idea of
going like knight f7 bishop hd maybe
it's slow
now there's always this question do you
take on prasad i would say maybe you
should
really i would actually that's sometimes
annoying to me that and then before
actually believe it or not
i think he's seriously considering it
but we'll see i don't like it because
the knight c7 96
isn't it like easier for players now
that is true but
my point is if you can maybe attack the
spawn quickly go knight b3 and c5 but i
also agree with you
it can get out of hand as we said but
yeah i think he's agonizing over it
he's looking at the time he's spent
almost half of his time already this is
okay so he's gone queen c2 now g5 is an
idea
and then queen g6 i've seen the sack
before g5 takes him
queen g6 yeah
and h4 knight f7 so tricky king i don't
think he did
though but
now this gives him the flexibility of
potentially going bishop h6 activating
this bishop would you play long castle
and king b1 okay
yeah well i i actually would i would
castle then go for g4
quickly because it's very hard for black
to attack
[Music]
right that's why i would castle first i
think
and then g4 e4 still is an idea but yeah
he does
i think not bad how we handle it not bad
i like it very pro
again very practical now maybe knight c7
and a quick p5 is that any good
i don't think so i think white comes
faster with g4
yeah yeah ah maybe king a cheat
just remove it like for g4 stuff i don't
know
brace for impact would you go g4 i would
but he's gonna access you of course
would i would
exactly yeah just go for it but it's
hard for black to to make a move here um
because gf is definitely a threat and
it's a positional threat
as well because it gives it gets the
four square
knight at six interesting
one yeah keep the tension for sure i
would play rook to one rogue g1x ring
the king while you're at yeah i agree
completely
i mean that he's hoping of course for
this and the knight's gonna get access
to this very strong square but
okay five very committal
f4 what if ef gets this
beautiful i guess he wants bishop but
very concrete
i don't like it something is off about
this idea though if you just move your
queen away you know
we need three yeah
you know me like better than i know
myself
uh you you see a trick and you go
forward
knight knight coming to g6 what do you
make of this
that's a classy move but what about fe
yeah i mean it looks good i'm not saying
it's necessary i don't like fv though
because that forces black to introduce
structural weaknesses in his position
you would want a knight to land on okay
rookie yeah what i'm not sure about
yeah yeah if he was the way you're right
fe was the way
i feel like they're they're playing this
cat and mouse game where they're both
afraid to just
step on the gas pedal now e4 should be
considered maybe
i don't know should it be considered is
that anti-position oh
i love when black plays e4 usually
because you get this beautiful
blockade on e3 and then some true yeah
i was thinking of combining it maybe
with a quick bishop d7 and b5 but i do
agree with you even that is not
it's a little bit too vanilla
we need seven
i don't like that move at all yeah yeah
no no no this looks bad now knight f3
queen d7 was i'm pardon my french but
that looks like a
really weird decision by bukesh there
now h4 has an idea too
and now these pawns start running queen
d7 versus i love white's position
agreed this knight on h8 that's where it
will remain if he's not careful
and i like the fact that it's three
minutes so we are already in the time
pressure
we are and that's going to be ever again
this is going to be a lot of fun knight
f4
active indians 90 does manage to you
know
rush past the gate before it closes h6
bishop each have to do it
here we go g6 has an idea
some point knight to six maybe just put
the knight back right but then we should
page five yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
no really i think bishop f4 and g6
he's playing prophylactically he's six
now i always just go g6
yeah he's like position slowly but okay
he does it anyway but no but now it's
not doesn't work rookie six is a
positional idea as well in the same
positions right
no but this has gone completely out of
control
f3 yeah trying but it's like you know
the lone ranger
i mean g6 here as well he's setting
something up here
look at arjuna it is so positional g7
now bishop e5 bishop f6 has to be played
nice
g7 and bishop d3 g7 and bishop d3 oh
what an idea
he's attacking the pawn how do you
defend it i don't like knight c5 bad
move bad moon
now black is id rook e3 no but take it
he takes an
seven he's seven he can't take it back
and too
soon he sensed the moment but this is
going to be appeared to be
too even too i could sense your
frustration you all
almost broke your mouse there yeah i
mean it just
it's like i could sense that he was
sensing the moment
and what to do now though luke is
continuing to find she has f2 he's seven
though
seven yeah wow
hats off to arjun i mean he just he kept
the schools he kept
his calm and he finds a really good idea
it's a time rusher
very nice that's a fun time pressure uh
chaos
indeed indeed and now a five point lead
yeah
was like the highlight for me
yeah i mean i it seemed like the game
might have been turning around but i
think he got too excited
you know knights i like knight c3 in
that position transposing into a jabba
is changing he has to change something
arjun proving like
really strong so far
yeah this should be three this line now
it's pretty fashionable line
i first side in the game uh i think
kikarina morgan's got a kamsky
in the us championship and since then i
think it became very fashionable
yeah just like to flex here that i
played it against levon arunian and i
won again
just nice just wanted to flex a little
bit here
[Laughter]
so you played with white yeah i played
with white
it wasn't world blitz though still the
flex just lost its meaning but
[Laughter]
you've you've beaten your share of super
jams in classical as well
more than a fair share the point is like
you want to play f5 f4 but then there is
always
knight e5 uh right and then that exposes
this knight
exactly and then i like this this
but then you go a knight f3 for example
right positional pressure yeah usually
i've seen people go g6 yeah
exactly knight g7 knight to five i
played a game with shimanov
uh and he did this and i was just he
wanted a piece
later but i was just much worse i mean i
just allowed ever like i didn't find a
way to stop all of this stuff
um and uh but again taking his time at
f5 he does it anyway
95 go for it oh 95 bishop e5 d5 f4
boom boom boom boom queen and if you
take on h5 he has rook f5 in the end
oh no no but uh there is bishop c5 as
well
after f4 ah so maybe direct f4 is a
better
uh better move got me all excited
and actually here whoops that
more people watching than hikaru's
stream
just wanted to say that which is very
rare wow
that's awesome um thank you everyone who
have joined
thousands and thousands of you and fans
from all across we know a lot of
fans from india staying up late cheering
on these
incredibly talented young players we
really appreciate
people's participation and hype uh it
makes our job
vetted i think a lot more fun and uh so
big shout out to everybody watching and
cheering on
um whoever you're rooting for by the way
bishop g5 very bad move
you i don't like it at all it helps
black
bokeh bishop g5 was not the way now h6
will trap the bishop
and it looks bad i will say that once
the games start i think in seven minutes
we'll see about the viewership but let's
keep it strong
how old are the players now is one
question i think it's seventeen and four
to fourteen yeah seventeen to fourteen
and gucash was the second
according to my research the second
youngest grandmaster in history
he was 12 years old um
and that is just that is mind-boggling
to me
still but i don't like white's position
e4 no that was really interesting now gf
and e5
yeah well not immediately maybe d5 hangs
but yeah
and i just don't like them now do you
castle long here
but that could run into like a5 a4 very
quickly even a5 here could be an
intimidation tactic
there's one message which says how can
within not know his countrymen wow
man i live in india we have billions we
are in millions
right and those kids who are so talented
so i can't know their age bad data
profile everything
no i i think that that is just a general
misconception about
you know countries with a lot of
talented players it's like you know
everyone personally you've trained
with all of them i mean think about the
proportion
and in the us i don't know you know
i mean i know of everybody but i don't
know many of them personally
by the way just one question like on
your streams
uh have you ever trolled like because
i'm sure we get trolled a lot by the
chat sometimes
have you ever told back oh absolutely
yeah i i actually do it relatively often
um
when i when i see a particularly good
opportunity yeah i know i do it often
um and i particularly like i like to
read messages that are intended to be
trolly messages
yeah a particular kind of voice which i
will not reproduce here but let's just
say it's not a very flattering voice
guys chat chat go for it
diana just asked asked you to troll him
you know this is your journey no it is
welcome then actually you know i
i do like um sarcasm i like
people getting fired up it you know it's
it it adds some color
yeah but there is a lot of color in this
position what is going on here i am
concerned about black center f3
e3 and bishop h e3 e3 whoa
yeah that is a knife black is winning
yeah that is a knife
and now arjuna will show his technique
you know take away everything
be better you might try something with
bishop h3 bishop we should see it bishop
see it who's going bishop h5 my friend
very positional very positional that's a
great move
knight f5 and then just bishop c7 even
like you know
you're not getting anything oh bishop i
feel like bishop hd bishop afterwards
ship c5 bishop g6 bishop bishop right gg
and if is queen d5 anything there though
oh knight yeah i got too excited for no
reason 96 queen e5
queen d5 i would not take on d5 i would
maybe even take on b7
you get a point oh that's such a good
move oh
and that is a good one ninety five
what to do now this is so crazy he's got
some meeting ideas queen e6 baby
queen e4 okay not a bad move but now the
queen
queen f4 24 okay and h2 i made a certain
quid h6 he's gonna move the rook now
knight f3 is a big threat he's got to
move
forward two seconds oh that's a knife
king one and that's knight
knight c5 oh man oh my goodness that
he's so impressive
he keeps putting all the pressure look
at this this way that way bishop d3
beautiful
my favorite game so far of the yeah it
was incredible
my favorite game that was so damn good
like
the accuracy level of arjun in that game
was amazing
how fast he put played really really
cool
wow i think we should show that seven
yeah you show that again let's see
if we can very quickly just uh show that
move as the game continues here
rook t so bishop d3 queen d6 by goku now
if you take the wrong queen fe check
and you lose the queen and arjun in a
second
rook d7 in this position
now the queen defends the rook you have
to take it takes
and it's a fork and you cannot you're
out of resources and this was just
part of it even before he found a lot of
good moves incredible stuff
this is very cool love it look decent
and
how he played before that you know to
even get there
uh because the position was little bit
dicey threatened some 181
in c2 ideas very nice very nice
respect absolutely and um
arjun here with the white pieces we have
a rogozin structure
the speed of rook d7 is still i'm amazed
by that
how great we played it because like i
could see
panicking you know it's like a fork and
you lose a piece and he just
uncorks it all his experience uh showed
up there
of this online blitz there is a time
control that i played with them which is
10 seconds to start the game and you
have a one second increment and he is
incredible that's where he shows his
ability to just find one resource after
another
by the way yeah i was thinking about
that i mean that seems like a favorable
trade
yeah but still i like black's position
definitely
by the way i have a tendency to say
portion instead of position
do you also notice that i
noticed it just as you said the last
time yeah
[Music]
okay oh g5 nice
nice nice spot there in the chat g5 i
did not bishop g3 the idea is to take
and of course
does a counter-attack though oh indeed
the transparent
that's awesome what if g4 do you have to
do that g5 g4
you do as no that's completely losing
the point yeah
king of one speaking h1n1 yeah
basically every game yeah
yeah what to do right it's almost losing
here that is uh
you see the face cam yeah he looks
completely chill like
he is so chill right there okay another
day at the office
yeah but with such a big lead i mean
you're just not too concerned about you
know one loss
and um 41 minutes left now this is not
over you know there's plenty of time
here
the cage does mount a couple of wins
yeah yeah at least destroying back one
interesting ghoukish is higher rated in
classical chess than arjun and his three
years youngest
good that's really interesting
okay so he's gone bishop e5 but
uh the problem is he might not even f3
you're not even going to take the bishop
you're just going to
knight oh but then he'll be four yeah
but even just
bishop before yeah he's done i mean he
has to
knight d6 e4 knight g3 also e4 knight
g34 94
by the way that's the way just 94 now
or here 94. yeah yeah yeah great catch
yeah this is the way to do it that is a
great that's how we wrote it
but it's taken and i think that's also
good right ed oh yeah yeah this is also
very good
very practical right high quality chess
right there classy decision right there
a sensing that it's just hopeless right
with that pawn on d4 phoenix
is what i learned from today's stream is
to castle and move the pawn in front of
the king
yeah it's been ubiquitous in these games
queen f6 laying it on i mean b6
okay i guess also good i just thought we
never should have had
were there any draws between them oh i
didn't think about it were there any
drawers
not at all no results that is critical
chad very nice very sharp what is
indeed now as you know what i'm thinking
rook f6 and then some c5 with knight g3
6 in the end
c3 i mean here you just got to be
practical maybe just take on d4
is there anything wrong with that um
no i don't see i don't think but yeah
it's just lost
when you get g5 or b4 i just forget that
i know kukish is going to win it mm-hmm
okay it's never over with arjun he'll
always find the chance
g4 c3
yeah just pushes the pawns i mean no
counter play basically
c2 simply drive it in
okay just don't blunder the knight on e3
right and very important yeah should be
three i mean you know when i get this
question i feel like you should
finish them off before they get a chance
like just kill
it yeah exactly i would say knight d1
here just wins on the spot i think
because the back rank is
yeah yeah yeah 91 is a good move knight
c4
bishop c4 probably also fine because
rookies
we need three no no no no no one
yeah that's over that's nice that's nice
right nice finish takes queen d1
coming back but of course it is still
wow five point lead even after that win
and he goes c4 so changing it up a
little bit
let's see what he comes up with here
nice nice come back so this
it was six two arjun has won two games
and ghoukish is won his first game in
three minutes section
now quincy to g4 incoming oh no
this uh actually uh nihal played this
yesterday
quite a few times against uh andrew and
robert and i were a little bit surprised
but i guess it makes sense i mean now
it's transposed into something more
conventional
d4 i guess i'm not sure that you usually
play d
you don't do ah you go like 92 yeah yeah
play but i don't know these positions
very well very simple
i mean 94 at some point might be
considered as well 92 young
c5 and maybe like you wait until the
right moment
to decide whether to play d3 d4 or
nothing at all
um sorry yeah oh
so is c5 um
i always used to love to play you know
94 and some knight f5
even at the cost of like some material
but just g6
yeah 100 tonight age four you just slam
it in there
yeah but it's all good in dreams just
like you know most of our dreams
exactly yeah it's funny how during the
game you just come up with these crazy
lines
in the queen sack and then you know like
not uh
scintilla of it will even happen but you
still keep thinking about it
hikaru is catching up he could have
crossed us over all right we need to
step it up folks step it off
knight c5 hype dream that's right d4 so
he does succumb to the d4 temptation 95
c5 you're okay
um 95 i like white how he's playing
you know just keep it casual yeah but c5
i mean
it to the good a5 okay a4
go a4 don't think what about h4
h4 you know you don't know yet he goes
g4 not h4
right the right flank
this is now i think of it you know he
might even go f3 g4 knight g3
who knows yeah no and then knight f5
no actually
[Laughter]
he's preparing some knight 65 ideas so
sort of prophylactic prophylaxis but a4
and now he gets the b3 score potentially
for the queen
arjun going after the queenside pawns ba
was actually a very committal decision
maybe it's time to consider g4
h4 makes sense now to trap the knight
but then you don't even have f3 because
right that's the issue yeah i mean it's
very such a such a super
you know artificial idea rarely works
yeah yeah yeah
what if you go h4 and then like king h2
alpha zero
there was one message which said that i
say gg
instead of gg what does what is the
difference
no i think you say it normally oh it
does
so i mean all right next game it's game
we go gaga
or last last game channel asking all
right so
wow you know queen's gonna just you know
just take the pawn on a4 and
well black's gonna get some pressure
pressured on the a file
so he does go f3 uh who's who's
impressive
is that wow what who whose do you think
that was
who does it sound like
a last game shot last game chat oh
hikaru
yeah okay i mean that wasn't great but
no it's like you know have you seen
anish's impression of hikaru
so it's just like he goes a little bit
over the top and then
that's why it's stuck in my head uh like
yeah normally i do as well
[Laughter]
your bitcoins like you know restricted
on this live commentary
all right right go wild watch cool
right all right it's queen bee three
everybody takes a four takes takes takes
takes takes
takes takes takes takes logical
all right so in any case but this is
heating up a little bit
exactly exactly right right
all right now bishop e6 is is that a
threat
b6 was a threat but then there was rook
before that's why
so that's why he played a3 now the rook
ship again arjun's so careful he keeps
posing problems with every move even his
defensive moves
pose problems now does he take any oh no
no then c7 that's bad
hikaru wants to know your location what
is going on
chess banning
that's hilarious take on c4
of course you would of course you would
i don't
yeah eddie jake's in rook c7
he did it he did it no but white is just
winning there i think
no there's a million ideas at the end
look how excited
can just take and play rook at seven now
i was thinking about that
but then queen g65 oh even better
oh my goodness wait what is this this is
not so clear
what if you give a check bishop g7 check
yeah yeah rook takes c5 and then
you find some good russian move like
h5 h6 what if you go
this this h5 and then and you can leave
the rook on cc okay that doesn't even do
anything
there is a beautiful idea though yeah
it's right six i like
i like i don't know about this now it's
okay
queen b1 at the very least
yeah but now it's like i feel oh time
for
some queen b1 check now you have to be
careful yeah that could be
possible b7 rook b7
uh e4 is nice nice but
but rugby seven maybe just right rugby
seven is less okay but he had to make a
move oh i don't like this at all queen
c2
queen c2 bishop g2 queen for queen f2 oh
yup yup yup
again it's those critical things he's
but now he's
yeah he's crumbling under the time
pressure winding his pockets with the
pawns queen d3 even
yeah yeah yeah okay no this was bad yeah
e5 five
the queen is so powerful in these
positions
kings king c8
king c7 f4 for bishop d5
yeah yeah just play bishop d5 he's gotta
try to push his h1 that's the only
option
yeah yeah h5 d3 h6 d2 right seven
queen h8 h7 d2 h7 oh quidditch one
and it takes a quidditch one back bait
quidditch what is it made
take stakes and then queen of three and
back to h1
what's a draw it's a drone wait it was a
draw
it was transposed to it no it turns out
only one oh my god he could have played
queen and [__]
and i was completely witty there was no
need for that at that point right
are you sure of queen f3 queen
oh [__] catch queen
before yeah
was there actually bishop f3 was also
probably me but then king f4
amazing stuff man i thought it was made
i missed
i think he missed the same thing i did
yeah which is definitely that square
all good blitz player missed the same
amazing it's nice some pattern
sebastian back to principled staff
rook a4 no rookie for a5 so you go
bishop a6
yeah yeah yeah
now you play castles or queen e5 yeah
queen d6 yeah rook b6 this is the city
yeah bishop b7 is the move here knight
d5 rupee two wow
castles and now bishop e6 bishop c6 is
the move
i feel the bishop
is out of the area first
queen c5 yeah it's good move quincy five
as well
bishop g4 man i would be so terrified of
playing this if i didn't know what if
this should be five check there
uh i don't worry know about it like i
just take everything
for night season king d1 and yeah
a3 indian okay but still pawn but yeah
who knows
bishop g4 though and even after bishop
b5 there is king f8
if required but again arjun's showing
superior superb preparation in addition
to everything else
what to do so bishop g4
well the thread is obviously knight f6
knight f6 that even though it might not
even be like a
whoa whoa ship c6 97 king e7 i think
it's all good
it's all good yeah queen g3 and now you
have to play accurate
uh words of wisdom there right i don't
know how accurate though
but i think rook 8 maybe 27 27 runs into
this maybe and if rook v6 like this
yeah that looks like king e7 queen g3
and then k8 maybe
so counter attacking the bishop
maybe give it checking f8 and zero zero
zero it's
so quick so sleepy though this is so
sleepy
yeah he's just moving around in
australia
he just doesn't now is rook v6 bishop e5
actually something
yeah it is something it's winning we
need six there maybe
he's done it look be one why not bishop
p5
i think this is it because bishop before
i maybe like queen e6
oh something i mean that's got to be oh
yeah oh but then queen takes a four yeah
but rugby
[Laughter]
okay so he's gone okay this is like he's
so practical
three he's got over three minutes a
minute it's got over three minutes look
at this
yeah over three minutes indeed it's
crazy
takes okay it takes it would be six
i can't believe it it's a brilliant idea
if the word defended
what's the big problem with squares
defended so what
now you know the pin is eternal you know
like queen c5
just queen c5
yeah i love the queen's 5's a great move
i was thinking h3 but there's no need to
make luft yet
yeah rook do you want also move i then
this is such an enjoyable position yeah
these positions are so fun
rook d1 does threaten actually bishop c6
and queen c6
but then black will go he does go h6 i
guess g6 uh
g6 is ugly it does look very weakening
queens if i go for it
my friend queen c5
you know quincy is one of the moves that
i want to play it and if it doesn't
happen it pisses me off it's like that
no i get it it's just such a move you
have to play because
whatever you do afterward you can do
after you play queen c5
nice nicely put you know why put off
for tomorrow what can be done today
which i never advice i never follow
g6 he's thinking okay he has three
minutes
it's better to think atmos at least some
point
about silence well taking a lot of time
here i mean
i don't understand why not queen c5 i'm
like what
is the counter argument to this
we need a breather here this is what's
going on
chad i'm taking how's it going how is it
going
how are you guys doing hope everyone's
enjoying the match we have
a lot of people across platforms we
appreciate it
um this has been a lot of fun a lot of
great games incredible performance so
far by arjun of course
rook d8 and queen c5 is that possible is
it even worth calculating that
so bishop fish queen are faking f6
queen h8 king e7 yeah
at least you gotta draw so right now you
don't have to it you don't have rookie
yet yeah
i missed that well that would be
something i would suggest
yeah let's see what happened he has
simply taken again very practical he's
not saying no i'm not calculating
anything in particular
i'm simply going to go for queen d5 i
think but i didn't like this h4 move you
know queen c5 was much classier though i
agree i agree
windy five now and then queen c7
rook d a first five now rook d7
[Music]
yeah the match is low i think it's yeah
it's not looking good here
yeah and six points is too much well
it's been done before
and i think it's been done once i think
the highest
and perhaps we can confirm this but i
think the six point comeback has been
achieved before what is the biggest
comeback
i think that might be the biggest one
but perhaps some of the historians
speech image pistols in the chat can
inform us
um now the thing is in the bullet
you can win two three games in the blink
of an eye so
23 minutes left if he wins two games and
he brings it to four
he'll have a fighting chance 23 minutes
uh for the three minute section right
correct he can't let this faster further
he's gotta bring it to four
and another one of those b3 g3 lines
okay she takes on d5 wait wasn't arjun
the one who played it the last time or
was it in fact
yeah it was arjun who won with black
with the crazy no
it was a draw this crazy perpetual in
the end
oh yeah yeah so d4 another practical
moment
i kind of like it i like arjun style in
general but i don't like the move or d4
which seems a bit too much it does i
agree this is a this is an extra pawn
after all
yeah and i'm greedy so i like pawns
extra
there's an old russian joke which is i
pointed it's not even a joke it's just
like something russian russians say
or russian coaches say when you sack a
pawn and like your coach thinks it's
unsound he says
there used to be a there's a russian
international master his name is
um and he the story goes that when he
was analyzing with people like tall he
was outmatched right he didn't want to
suggest any variations
but the only thing he would say is in my
opinion black is up upon
and and so my coach would always say
that in uh international master of
natsukanyan's opinion
white is up upon he'd say the one thing
he knew nobody could argue with
nice state the facts absolutely
but i've experienced this for sure where
i'm and you know
if i'm even near like have like the
world team champion should be bonjour
i'm pretty much sitting silent and i'm
just watching i'm
i'm so afraid of suggesting something
stupid
in during the analysis i mean i think
this portion looks good
for white completely yeah look at this
spawn on d4 is supporting the knight
wow square on c6 so
this is gonna be a big game if you can
get it relatively quickly
yeah and then that black game uh that
comes up is going to be
crucial assuming he wins this so knight
c6
no that's some so what do we do here
queen f3
and cd knight c6 maybe
sorry um what were you saying uh yeah i
was gonna say queen f3 and knight c6
maybe but
it seems like he's executing it mm-hmm
like cd nice
spectacle like one c7 yeah
what i've learned today is like be very
practical when it comes to blitz
you don't need to find the best moves
just play
uh normal like now 97 dc bishop f6 looks
good to me and i would probably go for
it
right no yeah exactly like find the top
one of the top
three moves yeah those problems
consistently
and i think uh is taking a page out of
argent's book here as he does that
yeah exactly that type d7 played
um probably just dc i would play right
now
knight d5 also a good move um
also good move 95 but maybe cd
and 95 queen e4 f5 you know
yeah yeah and like if
you need to there was a tactic bishop b8
oh
nice rookie now
wait a minute now he's got to be careful
and f5
rook takes e5 oh yeah rookie five you
have but okay still
still yeah i mean even in there so f5 i
think has to be played quickly
so f5 what we're saying is of course you
cannot take the pawn because the knight
is dislodged
it depends if the knight is dislodged
you have to play queenie for to keep
contact with the knight
unless you want to sack the queen which
is kind of out of the question to me
i mean i don't see anything immediately
wrong with queen d4 maybe black can play
queen d6
no but yeah yeah no you have to play
queen d4
he does by the way i see that
uh all of my moderators who are on my
youtube channel are in the chat so just
wanted to give a shout out to them
thanks for joining in
26 played now rook d8 rook d8 is a
threat
so maybe f4
[Music]
f4 f4 knight d7 97
f4 97 97 ooh
exposing yeah
what a tricky little well you know what
what what to do here
yeah yeah it's
come back you know such chances is
consistently missed oh wait what oh 97
97 seven queen queen freaking man
seven rookies six
every move is like causes these
calculational difficulties
quincy iv though yeah right
king h8 will be played instantly yeah
because otherwise there's discovery of
course are you
i say instantly and then he takes 10
minutes knight takes b6
i mean this has got to be bad now yeah
knight b6 is a good move
queen d2 king h3 even or king f1 both
just king f1 white will be fancy
yeah it's okay knight a5 now knight d7
is possible followed by queen before
queen takes a5
95 okay can you also go there's got to
be a win here
queen a6 greedy
i'm being greedy oh knight decent and
queen before is what you want to do
right yeah yeah just simplifying
knight d7 and recover the knight simply
and up two pawns yeah
taking a page out of arjun's book right
yeah just and i've also learned
oh wow queens is that actually good
i doubt seven takes c5 takes six yeah
it's still winning it's still winning
because you have two connected passwords
h4 h4 h4
i would have played h4 right the
preserve
okay rookie one rookie one go for it
rookie one rookie five
why ninety five no where is he going
yeah 95 was
no not g5 come on oh my goodness it's
main threat
okay yeah oh and nice
this is a game he had to win
he's panicking under time but okay six
2k6 he blundered oh no way to save jesus
nothing doing nothing yeah yeah
under the rook here amazing yeah now now
he'll win it off
bringing the lead to five now this is
the critical david and i think if he has
any chance of a comeback
at all which is slim admittedly it is
here it is in this game
five point lead with 15 what is this
i i think you're uh grishok i would love
to hear your grishok
about the match what do you think about
the match well i i
think that okay argent very practical
with
mutual time pressure of course he
avoided but
no but i think by and large she sort of
managed to get
kind of his positions and no i mean
i reminded me of course when i was
younger i tried to play similar
style and okay give a couple of years
maybe
then good will be a little bit stronger
this is so damn good man i'm fine
now i appreciate it yeah i've gotten a
little bit better at grisha over the
over the months no that wasn't crab
necro that
you know that's the worst when you do an
impression in people's lives yeah
exactly
exactly that's that's something right
exactly but i think most people are
concerned
no this is definitely not great this is
definitely autographic
i can't really do a good criminal but
kramnik is like no but i mean
okay but here no here i think white is
union okay but i mean
no but somehow i saw take could try to
try to make some progress but
but okay i mean i know but kramnik is
more generic okay
i think richard has that particular
accent i can't even really do a good
camera no
no i think your grifshook is like the
best so far
i love it
[Music]
by the way nice position over the board
like i prefer white very simple
to play maybe
he does a better grisham than grisha
i think wesley might be my best one but
i'll save it for
for a rainy day no there's too much
suspense
come on we can have a wesley but okay i
think people
maybe will allow it because they they
know that i'm i really respect these
players
and i'd like to thank for
the opportunity
that's good
but i'm holding myself back a little bit
yes yes i can see it
especially i can also try but again i
don't want that to be misinterpreted
no i don't think it would be
misinterpreted okay it won't right
now yeah uh vichy is a hero of mine
again
i want that to be known by everybody we
hear you're not indian so it's fine
you can sure okay
oh well i i think that uh well in the
opening i thought a good cache
got a good position but after h4 it was
uh
well i thought um it was a little bit
unclear but after uh well after the
opening i thought um
well i thought it was quite unbalanced
but uh well after that i managed to
create uh some chances and uh well
i took it all the way home
i would say still grisham wesley and
then uh
everything else yeah yeah
i think you can sense that it's very far
i think people who are like can't detect
the intonations like you can tell
anonymous is very far but i
i have some of it down i think people
say that
it's good most of the indians they
agreed that it was there so
that's a compliment in itself
yeah no i need to start practicing
others it's getting old you know
camaro and stuff like that oh komarov
yeah
man that's his commentary is lit i don't
know if people have seen it but
it's the best thing on youtube it is
amazing
now the knight comes to c5 and i like
get so excited
they want lego too oh
i try to do it knight p3 here for uh
arjuna and try to go to c5 and f4
here for white in is his position i
think he's definitely better now for f4
and eight takes b6 for guys in knight p3
knight c5
with the winning position here for right
i think this is
uh this is going to be winning kill for
sure b5 now get the knight to c5
and it's going to be winning this was a
lego yeah
yeah yeah it's incredible
i was very well prepared
yeah now this is actually total
domination for white by the way
this is yeah yeah clearly night
six nights you've got some in you yeah
nightbeat
now the only thing you've got to watch
right is the spawn on before which is
actually a little bit difficult to
protect
yeah yeah book c1
very methodical look at this pressure
that he's putting on
incredible i don't like ruxin oh knight
b3 queen before was the problem oh
right well that's the thing right a3 you
could have tried
yeah yeah
yeah now he has to keep control but how
do you do that queen
now knight b3 becomes a possibility
right queen e7
what if queen g3
oh queen c7 go for it queen c7 gg that
is such a
wait but queen takes before
you can't let me have the movement yeah
no did it no
you cannot have the moment i have to
take it before it's so good
queen before it's so good
yeah what to do actually because now the
knight comes to g3 yeah this queen
before is a nice trick yeah
bishop g4 knight g3
um not really there maybe queen c5 no
are we sure this is after queen c7 queen
before
yeah knight g3 go for it
careful now there's a fourth threat yeah
f5
is too much so bishop ca maybe
yeah it's typical dania move bishop yeah
definitely
oh bishop f3 rook c8 even ruxin
now f5 magnus carlsen
you have a potential there giving f1
queenie one by gandhi one he plays the
knights the
26th time pressure now takes 96
check will he leak with eight no he will
not
magnum hikaru nakamura knight before
check
in okay so anyways that was so good
i think komodo is there like it's one of
your top
yeah a little bit more work yeah
yeah nobody's there i could sense that
good good stuff
the roots d5 now somehow arjun
he he controlled for a couple moves and
then he just
right back at it incredible
giving that 45 he will win the game
queen is seven
night up for what is sufficient going to
win no it's not sufficient for what am i
saying
in different watch rook for who cap
seven check the
xd6 nakamura will win the game magnus
carlson queen c6 trade queen
and i don't know how he does it for
hours though
like i can do it and i'm out of breath
in two seconds
i love it this is stupid man i
appreciate it
yeah it's fun it's it's
yeah i've got a lot of work to do and
arjun wins
six also has a lot of work to do to come
back
you know guys now it's back to a
six-point game now he's got to win this
one seven minutes and
change left there's probably going to be
two more games in this segment
yeah seven and a half minutes left right
yeah close to one to c4 we have another
one of these um
but there's people like svidler who are
almost impossible to impersonate
yeah really i've tried many times cannot
seem to even come
close i've never observed him so closely
i think hikaru is because you see him so
often that it's responsible
right right right right exactly right i
mean
yeah yes exactly
but i think that there are certain
people who have you know
well it reminds me actually of a story
from why kansai
uh 1974 jen yes
so this is another one of those kind of
setups
before there we go again with another g4
yes's voice and that impression i almost
fell asleep that like so soothing
oh it is yes i mean the way that i tell
stories is intended
you know to really bring these
characters to light exactly precisely
yes and now give me the pawn
give to me the pawn he likes that phrase
yeah the yasser would take one also push
him baby
baby no what is that from you have not
seen this push him baby of
yasser or on chess bra they had like a
video made about it because whenever he
sees a pawn he's like oh push him baby
and then you know they made like a remix
of it
i haven't seen that i need to watch it
you should see this
that i definitely will i'll actually
write it down that sounds like something
i find entertaining
yeah so what do we have here so he has
taken the pawn in fact and now the g
file pressure this is kind of a typical
position that arises right
what do you make of this bishop i think
now
96 i would play by the way night before
some annoying move yeah
indeed yeah it seems to me i'm a little
bit skeptical of white's player even
though i like the style of playing
yeah you would take white don't know
still i would still yeah definitely
but king i would be grudging anymore you
have a thing for such
direct attacks oh i like that yeah
now the issue maybe don't just double
rooks play caveman style
he does go king d1 first people are
upset that you don't know push him baby
no i have gaps in my upbringing
i was too busy doing mastering
impressions
yeah and getting like 20 30 100 and
blitz
doing some irrelevant stuff exactly
exactly
so 96 now your move knight comes to b4
very unpleasant idea
i mean you have the open g5 but what do
you do about it
right yeah night before
tonight night eight
it's like you know it's not it's in
spirit
he played g4 and this stuff but he
probably doesn't like it
right in my opinion he's doing it
just yeah kind of out of desperation
almost he's got to try to generate
chances
quickly yeah i agree yeah
so d3 yeah now arjun's sort of spoiled
for choice he can go knight before but
he doesn't a four
knight but what is the idea 984 because
the queen then has the c3 squad also
yeah knight f4 i don't understand this
knight before queen c3 b5 then c5
that's a nice line let me show that
knight people whether it's here
92 and then b5 yeah even after
c5 92 oh so because you can just
yeah yeah you can interchange the move
order yeah exactly very very nice
takes doesn't mean it happens let's see
night before queen d2 has been played
he's played b5
knight back to c3
now time for black to okay now if you
take dc
okay knight e4 is not a move maybe yeah
yeah is it too risky to go e5
no no no f4 there's bishop f5 a3
e5 f4 and bishop f5
no but a b and bishop b3 then i think
you would do it no
i think he is preparing to sack the
knight and simply leave it on b4
a3 now would you think do you think
he'll play
i think he has to try a3 but maybe even
knight a6 you know that pawn becomes
weak rook g2
seems a bit too small i mean even if you
double there's g6 yeah
yeah jesus is exactly what i think is
going to happen
yeah yep knight h4 perhaps
try this action you have to know h4
should be eight
we should be eight without a doubt arjun
style i figured out arjuna after today's
match
i think i found it we're gonna go and
i'm not sure
d4 just provoked e5 you know yeah i was
thinking
yeah the knight of f5 becomes a threat
potentially yeah
what to do here is the question 30
seconds for
margin two not easy you know not easy to
find moves
right now to find anything really yeah
maybe cd
and then like e4 i i was thinking e4
right away and some queen n6 but it felt
wrong
f3 preparing e4
yeah f3 if you play f3 i'm just leaving
i'm leaving the commentary
right now you're hanging up there
exactly e4 e4
played yeah adapting queen h6 is an idea
then f
or d what do you do i think d these
looks more normal yeah yeah somehow yeah
and then maybe c5
knight dude it's heating up guys 94.
look at this
i like it i like it i need four you like
h6
rugby three knight g6 i feel like what
there should be
enough here but rook v3 first that's
very
good oh no yeah ninety-five
knights boxing him in winning the queen
no i wouldn't even play rugby two queen
h4 and play this you know just oh yeah
this is
everything yeah nice very cool very cool
amazing again okay not over yet though
queen f6 queen f6 gg is going to be a
massacre with queen c3 are you sure
though
yeah queen c3 look at how practical i
mean he's just safe and now he's gonna
go after him
amazing nice rookie two
four thousand very practical very
practical queen b3 knight c5
keep soldiering on queen b c3 played
although i don't like d4 yeah i think
that was sort of oh
yeah default was a big maybe he might
have chance now maybe right has chance
i don't think so though it's too too
much rook b2 coming in bishop h6 they're
coming in from all directions yeah
zombie apocalypse king f1 though
look at him quickly he says he's boobs
king of eight king of eight
bishop what queen of three
oh rookie one oh it's me
wow wow can you believe that
yeah that was very that was great that
was 15 seconds left which means one more
game and they aborted no i think they
are not going to start the new game
that concludes an incredible
i think three minutes section was my
favorite of like better than five
minutes for me
that was scintillating stuff and time
and time again arjun
proving himself up to the task putting
on incredible displays
in time pressure outside of time
pressure positional tactical all over
the place
and off to a seven point lead
coming into 30 minutes of the bullet um
your hot take video on that that was
incredible yeah
some nice games you know especially the
last
15 seconds when it got down to the wire
arjun really showed his class there
i feel very quickly finding resources
very practical
yeah very high quality stuff absolutely
and he's going to have to carry it home
30 more minutes of bullets to go kukesh
will try his best to mount a miracle
come back don't go anywhere
we will take a short break and when we
return the final portion of this
amazing match coming right up
[Music]
so
welcome back to the junior speed chess
championship
brought to you by chess kid we have
concluded
two of the sections the five minute and
the three minute section in this amazing
match between indian grand masters arjun
arigaisi
and uh bukesh uh it's been a pleasure
commentating and a privilege to
commentate along with grandmaster avidi
budrothy
and we have one more section remaining
30 minutes of oneplus one it has been an
overwhelming performance uh by arjun
but don't go anywhere anything can
happen now before we jump in
let's walk very quickly once again
through some of the logistical details
so we have 30 minutes left of one plus
one
16 players and here you can see some
information about
uh the structure of the uh of the
tournament itself
uh and now let's quickly walk through
the prizes because
these players are putting their hearts
out on the line but they're not just
playing for honor there's very serious
prizes on the line we see
the winner receives cool 2 500 and
what may be even more valuable to the
players qualification to the speed chess
championship
um which is of course a very very um
prestigious
event and a fascinating one in its own
right
so a lot of prizes on the line here and
uh finally
vidit the match score progression uh
which was always overwhelming for
arjun what do you make of that yeah and
first of all i would also say that it's
a pleasure
uh to do commentary with you danny and
uh hikaru
krishuk nepo all of your avatars
[Laughter]
and i'm just curious what is the
prediction and was it like so accurately
this um parameter but okay we have the
games have started we might get there
was like it was
essentially you know this is what was
predicted um
so was it like the exact same like six
enough to enough
and seven three and three plus one okay
i'd be interested if i i think um
i think we'll we'll find out but i i'm
pretty sure it's very very similar but
yeah i'm wondering if it's almost to the
letter but here we have liftoff um
exactly the same moves incredible now he
has played knight c7 before
i don't think he'll go long castle now
yeah
it would be fun to see who is good in
bullet that would be very nice
i still like g5 in a certain should be
five we should be five go for it yes
look at this i love your g5 idea i love
it if you can show it
right g5 takes queen g6 and then you
skewer the pawn on g2 you get this queen
out and you pressure
a g2 so you accomplish so many things in
one move
um i'm still thinking or no oh bishop f6
played nice oh my bad yeah so there's
couple moves played now queenie's seven
i like black's position here
white if he gives away this bishop the
dark squares around his king become
extremely weak i like
uh's position so far yeah
97 a very nice move i think 97. i didn't
want to exchange
yeah i didn't i thought maybe ah yes
knight 65 of course i didn't realize
that i was on v3 okay
bishop h4 nice provoking g3 good stuff
come back yeah i would like to put my
both of my rooks on f5 but i don't see
it happening right away
right why does control now he has
control
king g2 and rook a6 to be considered
yeah
yeah yeah i think in the last few moves
it felt like white out played black
right and look at the time situation 20
seconds up that is a huge time advantage
in the bullet now doubling on the a file
yup i think he's got to take on g3 but
here we see
the consistency of arjun is much much
higher bishop takes bbc
yeah queen d8 now this should be played
wait wait wait what he didn't take on b6
why now
now black gets some chances here wait a
minute look at white's pieces they're
all clustered take on g3 go bishop h4
he's got to try this
knight f6 okay he wants knight h5 maybe
c5 and d6
yeah yeah c5 c5 good move go for it he
has to switch
night h5 but now it's too slow you take
on g3 black's got to be winning now look
at this game
you distract
h
this is not the right way now the king
runs to c2 but then he wants queen f2
bishop takes a bishop b6 very practical
as well practical
aha no but queen b-1 is a threat he
might be missing queen b-1
we should be missed 24 24
yeah now this should be winning queen
a-2 and takes b-66
here we go he's taking 94 94. back to d4
take g6 though
when when you for queen you four knight
chief
bishop at six bishop at six okay
nobody's careful now e4 is a threat
yeah the ship's five now queenie three
becomes a threat no i agree with you
but this is unstoppable this is a huge
threat because
well knight g5 oh no actually king d1 he
goes
look at this stuff just finished 23.
he's just gonna keep
it i didn't like when f2 knight at 6924
yesterday tonight
oh my gosh he forces the queen trade
that's huge and now it's a draw
wow can you believe that
this is unbelievable i mean how to
survive this position and actually
watch white now get a better position oh
my god if white wins this
that's i will fall out of my chair no i
i actually
i'm so winning for black that was so
nice
oh no i think these are the moments
where gokesh is lacking where he had to
finish
him off i think at least two three games
it happened and the score would be
completely different it would have been
like nine for
arjun and then eight nine yeah so this
finishing off is so
so important hook is lagged there
and i mean of course kudos to arjuna
incredible defender was so so resilient
um just finding every little opportunity
it's crazy
um bishop f3
queen e7 queen e7 cd rook d8
no
somebody in the chat is angry
[Laughter]
not in the twitch chat in the chat.com
chat yeah
yeah sorry queen g4 looked at queen g4
oh one zero and you can't go g6 g6 he
still holds on but then takes a bishop
f6 maybe
yeah we should be saying yes okay goku
is fighting back
he has to convert such portions he does
yeah
good so far now he started well in the
last game two at some point though it
starts slipping away from him
threatening bishop f6 nice nice nice f5
oh bishop f6 what happens after bishop
f6
but then f6 again finding two chances
but we should have six no
we should be seven yep nice yeah i think
you've got to keep the bishops i mean
trading the bishops is already some sort
of admission
failure yeah yeah okay he does
f6 h3 just play yeah
maybe in quincy seven there we go
okay what to do now rook t4 something
general improving move like that
yep he's listening to both yeah but
thanks
for watching queen v7 ruxia bishop queen
b7
king f7 and then rook d1
okay c2 played a4 a4 right great yeah
yeah now queen is tied t7 if you take on
b3
you allow 27 yeah yeah yeah
before white is winning this a5 85 rush
yeah bishop b6 amazing you're calling i
like that you can
predict everything yeah let's say this
should be six
oh
queen a6 i thought maybe but again now
it becomes unclear
no queen c4 no quincy what you just
taken rook a1
goes here he stops the pawn from behind
now if he takes the pawn black is
pressing and this is crazy
okay five and again again not able to
deliver the rugby five and b3 is coming
that rook on d1 is defended he can't
even move the bishop
oh no man but he's got to go for it
yeah queen season quincy maybe
yeah yeah queen season yeah rupees 3
quincy 8 quincy it
[Music]
you know is the water ah quincy too
massive defense now queen
f5 no no no no no no queen c2 coming in
yeah it's just the technique you were
absolutely right um but it is just
lacking
bishop three king e6 he's gonna start
bringing the king in
oh i see that my discord has raided
welcome welcome what does that mean
discord like the people who you don't
you know discord right yeah yeah but
what does it mean for discord to read
like all of them who are watching they
just jump in you're like how are you
okay well welcome we've got a great
crowd here we've got
still thousands watching this match we
appreciate everybody so engaged
we're having a great time and uh we hope
you are as well so
big shout out to everybody uh watching
whether it's early or late
um wouldn't be the same without the fans
agreed
and this is going to be a draw painful
draw for ghoukesh
after getting such a winning portion
yeah he's the one who has to make the
draw yeah
but the bishop is anchored you know
without the pawn you can lose that
easily
yeah yeah yeah
hmm yeah draw and um
maintaining the seven point lead is
arjun
now let's see what uh oh bishop g5 look
at that
f6 here i thought is sort of the
critical move really
i thought knight f6 is the move no okay
doesn't that transpose to like a
trompowski with d5 yeah
yeah if you play yeah e3 and that's a
very that's a very profound point i just
mean there
it's the same like a4 queen b1 b4 isn't
it like similar
to that right yeah queen season i really
don't like
uh yeah this okay i
to just uh what to say disappoint the
fans i would say that the match is
almost over i think there's no coming
back for ghoukesh
uh but it's about pride now you know
bishop f5
if you can put up a good show and like
win a couple of games
that would be nice and in addition
there's prize money involved
because a percentage of the prize money
goes
based on the amount of games that you
have won so there's specific stuff on
the line and
i you know i don't want to put words in
people's mouths but
at least in my case you never just you
play until the last drop of blood you
know you might know that you've lost the
match
but you you know as you said it's about
pride and it's about efforts and uh
yeah you know there's still a lot of fun
games to go in the last 20 minutes here
so i would ask to chat if they want to
have like ask any questions
uh because we will be interviewing the
players after the match
so if they have any questions just put
them in i'm reading so
maybe we can ask them some fun questions
definitely
we should be five now 94. now he's going
to get the blockading square
oh but i thought he should have taken
bishop b5
right now there's a possibility of
trading knights potentially either
through f6 or three
rookie two yep yeah and look at the time
49 seconds of king f7 there's a3
no bishop v3 doesn't work whoa okay
knight h6 though
yeah rookie six but
is it something bishop e3 in the end ah
did this happen in the game it did oh
amazing but maybe ba
and then king h6 rookie five knight c3
try to catch that king somehow but i
don't see how
yeah king at six well he did wow
bishop g5 bishop okay he pushes the
beast and he finds that practical chance
how do you stop the fight
agreed agreed amazing very practical
now bishop g5 and rupert
what's happening is white winning why
it's winning well there's some past
pawns but rookie eight is unstoppable
yeah but then b3 b4 b3 g7
oh you gotta go
so sharp king but then rook takes d7
king no he's got to go here in d7 i mean
d7 has got to be winning
yeah yeah yeah and then luke g7 rook f7
gg rookie
action you know oh no again again
but
g7 unbelievable bishop g7 look at him
yeah
yep okay it's getting bad getting bad
yeah rookie jade wins and there is
enough resources there and resignation
we see that rating is not coincidental
uh he is worth probably even more than
than that
so experienced it will it's so fast so
accurate
so sharp it just turned i think after
bishop e3 i thought black was the
favorite but
yeah you got this idea with d5 it's
incredible
um now how tough it's just it's got to
be tough to play you know when you feel
like you're getting
pummeled yeah yeah yeah yeah you just
wanted to be over yeah
just wanted to finish bishop g5 yeah
nice move i think this is actually a
lion yeah
yeah but gotta keep
keep it going you know you have to uh
have to try to score some on our goals
bishop okay so now
wait a minute there was like queen f2
but d5 was p7
objection nice what if rookie five
no this is probably not good why not you
should find out d1
bishop d5 bishop p5 no no i didn't want
to play bishop d5 i want to play rookie
7.
that would have been really interesting
he's got queen a4 though
okay queen e3 not bad not bad rookies
now they're like slicing through queen
d6 might come knight c6 though
oh nice but 26 27 maybe maybe at six has
to be played okay
yeah now i think it switches over one
zero one zero
with the comeback win
yep do you think he's just freezing no i
think he'll resign after bishop d5
he will he i think he will sign after
bishop c6
i think he'll resign maybe after bishop
v7 he will resign
it did there we go finally
fifth time is the charm that was a great
game
um now come back as they start the next
game we just want to show one more time
the match score progression
um as we see slowly building up
that lead um was arjun
of course uh you know bit by bit
the word to describe this consistency
as you were saying from the very start
yeah just
iron clad boa constructor chess
and so tactically sharp and um he just
kept on
i think when it came to this time
pressure moments there was a big big
difference there
between right issues play and uh arjun's
play
now a question what do you like to ask
actually yeah that's it
see i always i'm gonna be wide open
about this i think that's my weak spot
of commentating i'm really like i'm not
good at inventing questions on the fly
it's not that i'm not interested in
their thoughts but i never
know what specifically to ask so
one thing we could ask i guess is like
it's all the cliche question you know
did you prepare
yeah how did you prepare
are you upset are you happy that you won
yeah
so maybe the the chat can help us here
what do you think do any questions i
want to ask
[Laughter]
like he's about to just like after the
match he'll just sleep right there
right he's on that very chair that looks
like a comfortable chair
and i can see that gurkish is upset on
the camera i can sense that
yeah that head in the hands and we see
the live odds five percent
now for and i mean that's so if uh arjun
wins who would he play in the next match
uh great question i don't know off the
top of my head let's see if we can get
that
uh and we have our amazing producers
pulling up the bracket right there
he will play um let's see the winner of
jeffrey jean against uh notre dame
uh i guess jung i guess yeah definitely
heavy heavy favorite is jeffrey but
nordenberg is a good blitz player so
it's going to be an interesting match as
well
but most likely jean um
okay cool you know yeah but we'll see
i see there is another grand master
ronald sadwani in the chat who's also
playing this tournament he says vd arjun
sleeps at four i know him
[Laughter]
all right so that was that rumor was uh
maybe he's just
that relaxed chill he's just chilling so
relax
by the way knight f5 is it winning now
knight g8
i think it is look at that knight king
to c3 yeah
coming nigerian even 95 both the moves
here
yep getting out of here very nicely very
nice catch
yeah and now where do you go oh oh
double attack just
knight six is the key c6 will be played
now
it just resigns yeah why but i
don't think it was resignable oh maybe
there was knight g5
right and it's you can get a little
tilted that way you know i actually
will admit that when i get really tilted
i tend to do that i start resigning
really really early when i like lose a
pawn
you know what i mean you just start
resigning i've never seen your design
when i'm very tilted i can totally do
that
i'm a late resigner normally i can be
quite obnoxious in my late resignation i
admit
but i don't know i i always felt like
i feel like it was not so much of a tilt
today it was just
the strength i think arjuna was much
stronger in blitz
in my opinion do you feel the same
completely i mean it's just the strength
to saw evidence
in every aspect um consistency but also
calculation positional game ci day every
time control it was showing
um so incredible i guess usually
in the first rounds of this tournament
uh first like in the knockout it's
usually like
the score there's a big difference but
as it gets closer
um second round third round and the
finals the scores are much more balanced
i would say like it's a very close fight
right
now bishop c5 by the way only moving oh
yeah
take that knight out of the picture yeah
yup he does it oh i see another
very popular streamer anna is in the
chat shout out
and uh we appreciate so many awesome
people raunak you know
all the fans here to accompany us is the
match draw still clause
queen b2 should be played yeah you know
that up now the queen
okay he does this now beef
big foot is asking where is my shoulder
okay bigfoot you
yeah we're not gonna give you a shout
out because you're no
you have too much power exactly but
white is definitely better
i think toward the end here he's playing
well queen b two had to be played by the
way rookier i don't like
yeah but he doesn't need to care now
this is like a seven this is such a nice
position 965 even yeah
97. how much time is left
10 minutes on the dot just a little hair
under 10 minutes now
so i guess three or four games would be
played right now yep
so let's see if uh lucas can make it a
little bit closer he's got this end game
up upon will he be able to convert
which he has had been having trouble
with the whole match
he says we yeah we gave him a shout out
he timed out two of your mods and i'm so
happy
oh this is this is cruel 94 by the way
is interesting
94 a rook
[Laughter]
so good oh i would never take on e6
i guess he wants rookie five yeah but
still very very concrete
so did you win like last two games or
what's the deal
no no no arjun won the last game right
right right
yeah so nice game there
and um yep nine minutes left exactly in
the match
it means gambit here bigfoot exposed is
going on
oh yeah this is what we all really came
for
so
so yeah um what is this b5 stuff
i guess he wants a5 quickly
rubio knight is a b b 1 he wants this
and then he wants to attack this pawn
maybe i would take maybe i would take on
before first and then
he does that he's going to knight the
fight
it's all about seven check also by the
way oh that exists
yeah but we a double attack i mean you
attacked
six yeah you know
and we remind g6h4
and we remind the uh fans here that
uh the reason part of the reason they're
completing the match is because a
significant portion of the price
does depend on the actual number of wins
even if the results of the match has
been decided
uh which i think is a great touch i mean
it's you know
it's fitting to conclude the match um
and uh they're continuing to fight as we
can see but h5 oh
95 yeah
he's now just playing for the crowd
h5 but i think this is really good it's
so satisfying to win such a game by the
way
with you know with such domination
and now i would add some sacrifices to
the mix like some bishop gt ideas
which doesn't work obviously but this is
arjun he will play like very
consistent knight g4 kind of moves no
he'll play bishop d3
yeah he'll just almost yep got it whoa
look at those squares
i guess now i'm able to guess his moves
um i think he's going to go knight c1 to
d3 at some point or maybe not
knight c maybe just takes no knight c5
bishop d5
oh bishop d5 should be four
look at the mango queen c5 he'll play
queen c5 or bishop c5
if his spawn were on a h7 that would be
a little bit better yeah
but still good enough what is it rookie
[Music]
h7o
so the king can get h7
wow i'm just i was just thinking if you
could uh ask
them with your grisha accent yeah some
questions afterwards
do you think they would they appreciate
it you think i should actually do that
look at arjun i i think he doesn't care
about anything whatever you do
right but it now
me of me of course i also don't really
care
what anybody does i simply
make decisions based on what i want yes
um
yeah watch grishav just he's going to
knock on my door right now like
i'm not happy with this no but i'm a big
fan of your christian accent man i've
never seen a grishok accent like this
yeah well okay sometimes it's basically
what i do to pass the time
yeah origin is like 92 yeah sorry
sorry you're seeing something no no
nothing nothing of substance
like most of the things i say i guess e4
oh yeah he does play e4 yeah e4 oh the
d4 square is yielded but
no it's pondo three points upon in the
opinion of uh international mastermind
canyon
[Laughter]
only those who watch the entire stream
know that reference exactly no
but it's like such all the russians know
that reference
you'd be sort of old-school russian
players but now everybody's going to
know that which is great
and this looks nasty nasty for white
there's a huge demand for anish accent
but i think anish's accent is tough to
pull off
very he speaks so fast he speaks so fast
that it's very hard to mimic him it's
yeah it's similar to nepo in some way
but uh
i promise uh give me a week or so
i'll work on that next i'll give you
guys my word
anish accent coming in in one week
indeed
it's yeah it's similar to nepo so i
don't think it'll be impossible now d2
by the way is is interesting if i should
g5
or maybe rook c1 roxy one d2 oh yeah
ruxin ruxin d2 seals the deal
oh bishop
yeah eight seconds knight c3 will be
played and then
uh bishop c3 no okay of course
our pleasure thank you for uh in the
chat
designs coming in nice fork 92.
yeah rook d1 with bishop p1 takes in
rookie eight
swing it back oh this rook t even more
precise
and three and a half minutes to go
probably two games left in
this match tough tough for bukesh now
down nine points
but he keeps fighting what to do such
is the nature of this game
agreed uh big margin by the way
i i think yesterday nihal won by 16 to
eight
right and today what's the score like 16
and a half seven and a half already yeah
right right i mean i honestly i expected
it to be a little bit closer but
i also think um yeah the form uh
he made very few blunders uh did uh
arjun
i can't even think of a single like one
move blunder he made
so i think the prediction was seven to
three in one plus one
by the uh i don't know what is that
called scc
prediction meter how dare you get the
name now smart chess statistical
analysis yeah meter analysis is so easy
of course it's rolls right up just
analytical statistical
an analytical database excel spreadsheet
analysis uh platforms i know all of that
talk because i'm from the bay area i
know that silicon valley talk
developing engineering platforms for a
better tomorrow the
integrating solutions and seo management
enhancement
smart chess prediction software analysis
it was close that's very close
very very nice name guys but a very nice
name
very easy to remember this is the most
anyone has ever taught and talked about
it
in its history
but yeah now again an advantage here for
white look at that pawn on e5
i guess the knight on d5 can be
dislodged with c4
yeah yeah
it's now all about pride right oh
look at these squares these squares look
at f4 by the way
can be considered here knight of the 96
yeah also yeah yeah he goes for 96.
of the show i know bishop g5 yeah i know
arjuna 98 if rook g7 maybe no no you're
going to should be five
he'll be bishop at six
he'll go an idea for the fans we should
read the fans
[Laughter]
oh
h4 though you just repeat it that way i
guess it's nick in the chat
oh totally yeah it's gotta be oh look at
these squares
my last day last day today here guys
after messing up that
oh you're fired knight g5 takes e6 look
at this knight completing its victory
tour knight d8 takes 66 takes the rook
this is a symbolic of the match and i
think that might have been the last game
or they have one more to go one more
seven seconds oh if he had not resigned
the game would be over
yeah and this is the last game folks
a 10 point lead yeah so what are we so
what are we asking
the players but it's uh pretty close
the smart chess addict analysis
prediction it is
very cool yeah it was seven three it
could happen
wait so what is the current score in the
bullet though it's six three no
oh my goodness so it's almost on the dot
that actually is really impressive i
know we were laughing about it but that
is really impressive
oh people are now writing uh the
questions
how sleepy are you guys trish
uh it's 1 a.m in india by the way
i when i only struggle with i don't want
to seem like i'm being obnoxious like i
know it can be very upsetting to lose
such a match and i hate to like
impinge on his recovery period you know
especially with gucaish
yeah and i feel like sometimes it can be
invasive to ask her oh like what went
wrong
bro let me you know let me reflect like
you just recovered yeah
yeah none of your business you know so i
struggle with that a little bit
so you want to go for the questions or i
should take charge
let's alter i mean maybe i can start and
then we'll alternate
yeah about that
so guys in the chat if you have some
questions which you really want to know
yeah we need help you really really want
to know
uh some more by the way instead d5 want
a piece there i think
oh yeah we should be thinking yeah
whoa
yeah yeah maybe like
we are in sync there rook d7 coming in
so
smart chess prediction meter you might
be just wrong by one point there
or not oh no or not or not
but uh ef now i actually have a
potential idea from someone in the chat
i remember kramnik hosted this camp with
top indian
talents and they played no castle chess
yeah and maybe we could ask them about
their experience
playing no castle chess and if they
think it's actually you know worthwhile
yeah you can go ahead with it by the way
just again proving smart
because before b3 and now arjuna i think
black's going to win it it's exactly
going to be 739.49 c4 coming in
but nine seconds left yeah
amazing yeah don't play rookie five
yeah rookie fight rugby it was also okay
rook d4 looking 92 oh no
now the knight comes to f5 f5
no no he won't play five g6 you will
pretty much
don't know arjun yet yeah it's just i i
can't
knight f3 and rook d a would have been
interesting with some mating ideas
he like does the second thing first he
wants to trade and then mate him on f3
oh it's almost mate rookie takes this
one
knight d3 such technical play knight of
four check
yeah 96 rook d4 knight p2
collects all the pawns and he shuts him
back down
yeah now i know arjun how he plays
96 rook a7 but i don't think he played
that
particularly well here i think it was
overly technical if anything
but he's explaining he doesn't need to
f4 and mate on
f4 go f4
okay now i hope this doesn't last for
another hour
okay the match is over guys the magic
all right folks all right guys
all right hey guys it's john all right
f4
g3 he's still trying to win yeah
yes yeah it's the well i understand i
mean competitive yeah
yeah but
whatever guys is it happening oh no i
thought g3 was a nice trick there
oh and samaha yeah oh g3
wow
please don't play this 400 moves yeah
i'm also
solemnly asking these players to
remember
that the match is over and yeah
yeah yeah save it for the next match
right exactly
all right we have five
thousand almost five thousand people
thank you everyone for joining in
and we've only grown that number despite
a minor tournament going on so we
appreciate it this has been amazing
we will say our proper thank you uh at
the end if this game ever ends but
the thank you speech yay indeed that's
what everyone's waiting for and there's
just going g3 arjun
yeah just go finally thank you takes an
f2 but this is going to last again for
another 30 moves
oh you might meet him though how
where's the mate i asked my mother the
how i'm not a specialist in high energy
we should have fun we should have fun
i don't like bishop g2 but again it's
fine
yeah draw no king f3 but then bishop f1
yeah okay
my first question is going to be arjun
why you just didn't take the draw there
yeah
yeah just take it
end the suffering
this is crazy the last game of the match
what the hell is five ditches
i just see oh it's i heard of it there
we go
finally seven moves and that concludes
officially the match 18
to eight in favor um
of course of argentina guys the
incredible performance
um indeed by him in all sections across
all games and i believe we will take a
very short break before returning
with the interviews um yeah we will
break very shortly and when we come back
interviews
with our two competitors
[Music]
so
welcome back ladies and gentlemen and we
have for you um
today's two competitors grandmasters
arjun uh arigaisi
and uh gucash domingo uh arjun
congratulations on an excellent
match um we felt vivid and i felt
throughout the match that you
demonstrated
very very practical play very consistent
play
uh did you make some sort of conscious
decisions before the match
as to style or did you just kind of play
your usual chess and things went well
i just did my usual check and it worked
out quite
well yeah we were impressed throughout
it yeah i noticed that many times you're
taking like practical decisions
um so according to you what do you feel
uh was a critical moment and where did
you start feeling comfortable in the
match
[Music]
i think at first i was quite comfortable
but then in three plus one i lost one
game
and i was on a slide till but
it didn't really affect me
and what about you uh what did you think
went wrong
uh for you in the match it was close
little many games i felt
that you had chances but you couldn't
convert where arjuna was very
what say um very resistant so do you
think that was the deciding factor
what went wrong for you
yeah i think in the opening you know i
was
better in many games but
the last seconds like uh below 10
seconds i was not
able to
well fair enough fair enough and uh that
was very well played
uh and well fought by you as well well
we will not take up any more
of your time we know it's very late for
you and you've just played a very
difficult match
congratulations once again uh arjun on
an excellent match and
kukesh to you as well for for a great
fight um
and thanks uh both it was a pleasure
pleasure to commentate the match
goodbye and
well that concludes today's match vidit
what is your hot take um
what is sort of the word that describes
today's match in your opinion
i think it was a i i don't think there
were like big blunders or something i
think
um the match was played at a pretty high
quality for blitz
and i felt like just in the critical
moments as gurkish pointed out that
arjun was much
more tougher and uh very sharp in
tactics so
i think he deservedly won the match no
indeed
i i agree completely well before we
conclude let's take one
more look at the bracket of course we
know that
arjun has advanced he will play the
winner of jeffrey zhang against
norderbeck abdusatorov
of course jeffrey is the favorite that's
going to be a fascinating match and we
remind you
that the smart chess prediction which
today was
kind of redeemed predicts that nihal
sarin
who yesterday scored a convincing
victory against andrew ting will go on
and win the whole fake but of course we
have so many close matches
to come this is only the beginning we've
already been treated
to some incredible chess and
unfortunately
today comes to a close but we have so
many more days of action
um did it it was a real privilege and
and uh
pleasure to be commentating with you as
we take one quick look at the scheduling
we have a whole month of action thank
you so much uh this was
awesome thank you daniel it was great
commentating with you
uh looking forward to more more of this
stuff
absolutely and uh we want to send a huge
thank you to the thousands of fans
over five thousand on one platform and
throughout platforms who were
staying up late and cheering on the
players
uh and participating in a very lively
chat this would not be possible without
you so we really
appreciate it uh and with that being
said
uh thank you everybody um this was gm
daniel there it is he commentating with
jim vida gujarati
we hope everybody stays safe have a
great rest of the day
and we will see you during the next
match goodbye peace
[Music]
so
you